[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
thank you
[Music]
foreign
foreign
in Milwaukee Wisconsin and even though
football season is in full swing the
cheese heads are flocking to American
Family field to cheer on the first place
Brewers now the magic number is down to
three for Craig council's Club to clinch
the NL Central but Yadier Molina on the
red hot Cardinals have had something to
say about that as they look for the
sweep and what has been part of an
incredible run that has put them four
and a half games up in the Wild Card
race as they look to make it 12 in a row
it's an NL Central match up here on
YouTube as we welcome you to the MLB
game of the week pregame show presented
by Jim Beam what's up my friends Lauren
Gardner Heidi Watney here with you in
studio 42 here to MLB Network dude how
you doing another pre-game show the last
of the Season I'm a little nostalgic I'm
a little sad a little sad about that a
little sad about that but really hyped
for this matchup today Brewers and
Cardinals two teams that are headed for
the post season and we've got Adam
Wainwright on the mound the dude has
been fantastic one strike out away from
2000 for his career with four Innings
pitched today he passes the 200 Innings
Mark and he's doing this at 40 years old
he found the Fountain of you somewhere
and I'm gonna come ask him where I just
wonder exactly it's probably like a lot
of kale and like wind Sprints I don't
even know maybe he uses like some sort
of collagen inducing light mask but
we'll find out
sure he is but as the cards look for the
sweep here in this four game series
we'll take you back to our last night's
game 10-2 victory in Milwaukee
one on four St Louis and Tyler O'Neal
coming up and O'Neill jumps on it and
that deep left two nothing sailor they
strike in the first again popped up left
side Ariana giving Chase oh
went over
[Applause]
and goalie hits it out to a deep left
how far and it's a 10-2 Saint Louis lead
so today the St Louis Cardinals will
look to equal their franchise's longest
winning streak in the last 40 Seasons
against the Brewers in the long history
of the Cardinals they've only had a
winning streak longer than 11 games
three separate times in 1982 they won
the World Series in 1943 they lost the
World Series to the Yankees and when
they won 14 straight it came in 1935
where they finished second in the
National League behind the eventual NL
Champs the Chicago Cubs not too bad not
bad at all so check this out currently
in second place Indiana Central are the
Cardinals as Brewers magic number we
just talked about this earlier is down
to three so meanwhile in the NL Wild
Card race the cards have opened up a
sizeable lead as you can see here so
with 11 days left in the regular season
things are getting real and that's
exactly how we like it my friends and
it's time now for unboxing the matchup
as we welcome in our very own Sarah
Langs of mlb.com uh Sarah it's always
good to see you my friend we may as well
start with the hottest team in baseball
right now the St Louis Cardinals who
were not on everyone's radar in
mid-august so tell us how their playoff
odds have changed
oh my goodness first of all thank you
guys so much for having me but the
Cardinals this has been an unreal
stretch as you guys were saying with the
wind streaks everything else so they're
now up to 95 playoff odds that is
nowhere near where they were even
earlier this month so on September 7th
they were at 2.8 playoff odds and I love
to look at these on fan drops you can
pull up an actual graph on fan graphs
and see a chart of where the playoff
odds have been all season and theirs
just shoots up right over these last two
weeks or so it's been so cool to see and
Heidi I love that you mentioned that in
1982 they won the World Series because I
was going to mention that going for win
number 12. last time they did this they
won the World Series
yeah they won the World Series over the
Brewers now while the Cardinals pushed
to a postseason Birth has been
surprising so has the performance of the
40 year old Adam Wainwright who's
pitching incredibly in his 16th season
he's going to make his 31st start he's
likely going to go over 200 innings for
the first time in seven years but Sarah
you've noticed a unique way he's getting
hitters out
absolutely so one thing he's been really
great at this year is getting cold
strikes and especially called strike
threes so he has 65 called strikeouts
this year which is third most in the
majors behind Sonny Gray and Zack
Wheeler and that's something that he's
really excelled at this year and you
know we can mention Yadier Molina there
obviously there's some help from your
catcher when you're getting a lot of
those called strike threes and Yadi
actually doesn't even rank that well in
framing metrics but I wonder if it's
just that Rapport that he has with Bueno
all of those starts they've made
together we celebrated the 300th one a
couple of weeks ago and you can see the
list right here 65 called strikeouts and
he's had more than 38 of his strikeouts
this year have been called strikeouts
the MLB average on that is 23 so that
just tells you that's something else
that he's doing and with an older
pitcher like him he needs to get crafty
he needs to be doing something different
and that's where he's elevated his this
game this year yeah we know and Yadi
that is uh that's a package deal there
and that's the definition of chemistry
so now let's get you over to the Brewers
who are on the cusp of clinching the NL
Central we were saying their magic
numbers down to three so we've heard all
the names this year from William Thomas
and of course the turnaround that Keys
had to the Brewers Christian Yelich
who's getting his back going but it's
been a guy where some have wandered in
the off season if there was a spot for
him and that is our friend of aseel
Garcia
yeah he has been so good for them I've
been following his career his entire his
entire time and back when he was on the
White Sox and in the AL Central people
always used to call him like mini Miggy
that was kind of the reputation that he
had but he has become this great power
speed guy so we really see that from him
earlier in the year he was on that list
of guys in the 90th percentile in both
he's a little bit further down in his
hard hit rate but if you take a look at
this so barrels this is Barrel
percentage barrels are basically your
ideal contact that you can make the
ideal combination of launch ankle and
exit velocity and you can see that he's
on the list along with someone else
who's playing in the game today and
Tyler O'Neill in terms of the largest
increases in Barrel rate from last year
this year so that's really what he's
been doing differently he's always been
a pretty good hitter but he's really
crushing the ball this year and he's
been able to help carry that offense at
times before they had Willy adamus and
even in conjunction with him while he
was injured and with Christian Yelich as
you mentioned not quite getting that
back going yet maybe looking to a little
bit these last few days but obvi has
been really the go-to in that lineup
yeah they certainly hope they can get
yelich's back going we're going to talk
about sleeper teams in the postseason a
little bit later in the show but aside
from their excellent starting staff the
Brewers also have a dominant back end of
the bullpen that could be tough come
October tell us about their dominance
definitely so in Josh Hader and Devin
Williams they have two of the three top
relievers in terms of whiffery so that's
getting swings and misses which as we
know in postseason games and just in
general at the end of the game that's
what you want to be seeing you don't
want to see ground balls out of your
relievers you want to see those
strikeouts that's the most definitive
way to make sure you are winning that
game at the end hater leads and Majors
Devin Williams is third you can see
they're the only Bullpen with two of
these guys and it's amazing we've talked
so much about the starting rotation this
year and with good reason it's been
incredibly dominant but we haven't
really talked about how outstanding this
Bullpen is and these two guys are having
great Seasons yet again Devin Williams
has a 255 era it was like oh 33 last
year so of course it was going to go up
a little bit without the 60 Game season
but he's still been outstanding and
hitter has been such a reliable piece in
this Bullpen for the birth for a while
now and it's just great great to see I
mean they have the complete package on
the pitching side they've got the
starters they've got the relievers and
everything comes up Aces for them yeah
everyone knows how good hater is but
Devin Williams isn't surprising anyone
anymore like he did last season thank
you so much for joining us Sarah
thank you guys great to chat with you
yeah all right that's going to take us
to our poll question and it is who is
going to win today's game the Cardinals
or the Brewers please go online and vote
all right we'll have the results for
that poll question later in the show
we're also going to talk to Tyler
O'Neill his family pedigree may surprise
you you'll want to hear what he has to
say and we'll have our picks to click
well the Cardinals extend their winning
streak to 12 games or will the Brewers
lower their magic numbers stay with us
the 1-2 pitch by Alex Reyes got him
strikes out the side in the eighth the
O2 pitch
strikes out the side here in the night
Reyes struck out the side of the eighth
Whitley follows him a ninth and the
Cardinals win it by the final of seven
to nothing
O'Neill with a Drive In The Deep Center
and gone Tyler O'Neill in New York the
2-2 O'Neill when they drive
[Applause]
what a great moment
and Carlson sends a Fly ball out to deep
center it's at the world
grand slam for the rookie oh what a
moment here he push
[Applause]
and Almanzo hits it out to deep right
nude far back
large
the catch and he robs Alonzo
laughs
welcome back to the MLB game of the week
pregame show presented by Jim Beam
one of the Cardinals best hitters is
Tyler O'Neill since about the middle of
August the Redbirds outfielder is
hitting over 320 with an Ops over a
thousand one of the main reasons why St
Louis are nearing a post-season berth
and with that I want to welcome in Tyler
who was just named the Chevy player of
the week Tyler congratulations that's a
pretty special honor
thank you ladies much appreciated
feel to be named the Chevy player of the
week out of everyone in Major League
Baseball
yeah I mean it's a good feeling
um you know player of the week's play of
the week so it's a great honor of mine
uh absolutely um you know I'm just
trying to do my job in there and just
try and get hit when the hits when the
boys need me keeping things simple and
uh you know this is what's been working
for me so far yeah what has been working
so well for you at the plate so far
especially when you're hitting there
between Goldie and Nolan Arenado I guess
that's pretty good company to keep
yeah that's pretty fun
um you know obviously those two are such
bookmark hitters especially in the NL
last last decade I'd say so um you know
be the guy hitting in between them
um you know being able to back them up
when they need to different things like
that uh it's been a you know a big
learning curve for me and and uh you
know a great experience for me this year
yeah those are two pretty good names to
learn from I'm sure you picked their
reign another good guy to learn from is
Dad hops is a bodybuilder and he is
ripped you you look pretty ripped
yourself I'm gonna have to say uh who
wins in an arm wrestling competition
between you and Dad
yeah I think I think Terry's still got
that old man's strength so he might have
me in in the in that department so uh
you know I learned a lot from my dad
he's a great role model icon for me uh
growing up getting into weightlifting
and stuff and uh eventually put me on
the map for baseball okay so you're from
BC obviously you start skating before
you can even walk up in Canada but uh I
I've seen you attending some games there
in St Louis are you obligated to say
that you're a Blues fan or is it are we
going with Vancouver are we connect guy
are you going to go down to the Kraken
yeah obviously I gotta stick with the
hometown Knox uh you know those have
been my boys since day one and um you
know obviously starting a career in St
Louis as a Canadian has been a great
experience for me so uh picking up the
blues is another sports team has uh you
know been been exhilarating especially
with them when a couple years ago
yeah it's a fun time yeah for sure there
all right I want to know you hit a home
run last night so you obviously like
hitting there what's your favorite
ballpark to hit in
got to say Bush you know there's nothing
like a bad zap Bush
everyone yeah favorite road ball you
have to hit in then oh it's a tough one
uh
yeah you know obviously it's not hitting
hitting here in um American Family feel
you know they got a nice batter's eye
um you know anywhere with like a black
tone batter's eyes makes the ball a
little easier to see um you know but
that varies by Park you got to adjust to
your environment and uh different things
like that so um you know some things uh
you see you see the ball uh better off
uh you know different ballparks than
others so wait she goes well hopefully
you're feeling good about either San
Francisco or LA because at this rate it
looks like that's where you guys are
headed all this talk about what you've
done at the plate defensively you're
turning into one of the best left
fielders in the game what have you been
able to work on recently just in that
respect
well yeah I mean I've kind of come a
long way on the defensive side of the
ball I think
um you know just really coming down to
the the basic fundamentals especially in
the footwork you know getting a
consistent throwing path uh just being
um you know making the right play when
you have to making making uh you know
dive and play When the situations right
different things like that so you know
learning the game has been a big thing
for me this year and uh it's paying
dividends both sides of the ball
well defensively obviously you've been
pretty good but you've made a lot of
strides offensively as well you have the
greatest increase in Major League
Baseball and batting average and third
greatest in slugging compared to last
season how have you made those jumps
offensively
yeah I mean learning the league a bit
um obviously last year was a bit of a
crazy year I think everyone can agree on
that so um you know I feel like this
year I've really starting to become the
player that that I should be uh you know
I know my skill set and stuff so
um you know again you know it's a big
learning curve this year especially
stepping up up through the lineup you
know not hitting in between Goldie and
Nolan you know it's got a it's got a lot
of I guess responsibility might be a
term uh you know you want to hold up
you're under the bargain to the boys and
be able to produce for those guys so um
I'm only going to continue to learn and
understand this league further so just
excited to see what happens going
forward yeah definitely a fun learning
curve especially with the run that you
guys are on right now obviously your dad
taught you how to show like which
direction the gym is in uh I'd be remiss
if I didn't ask you about what's going
on with the tats What's Happening Here
show us show speak
um yeah well my first one I don't know
if you guys can see it there but we
haven't got that Maple Leaf and then
yeah there you go it's that Maple Leaf
and uh that's the rim of my bedroom
window looking out with a sunrise and
then I got a couple clocks from with my
birthday and then one going to the end
of time basically it's kind of the idea
with some branches leading back to home
and then a corn underneath
um create your own opportunities or
something that I've lived by for a long
long time ever since I really got
serious into sports and you know getting
going like that so it's uh it's all a
piece of me uh it's not complete yet
um see where see where she goes work in
progress just like you I love that
for me
we love it we love it all right you guys
are riding an 11 game winning streak you
went from a five percent playoff odds at
the beginning of the streak to now
around 95 basically a lock for the
postseason now what has it been like in
your Clubhouse during this stretch
uh I think the biggest thing for us is
we've always believed in ourselves you
know we've had good team chemistry from
the get go-to but you know we we know
we've had that ability to to propel
herself into the postseason it's just a
matter of time before everything's
strung together you know lately we've
been hitting been pitching great you
know keeping runs off the board putting
our own runs on the board obviously
that's how you win games and uh you know
that that's that's how we're doing it
lately
hitting pitching and defense
thank you for joining us Tyler good luck
out there today thanks dude thank you
thank you ladies thank you
well we all know what that silky Jazz
means it means that it's time to offer
our creator Spotlight as we welcome in
Bobby Crosby no no not the former
American League rookie of the year but
the creator of the channel Dodger films
and of course naturally he's a Dodger
fan as you can see by his hat there his
favorite moment was Kirk Gibson's home
run from game one of the 1988 World
Series Bobby what's up my friend welcome
to the show of course your channel
Dodger films is wildly popular on
YouTube with over a million subscribers
so why don't you tell our viewers a
little bit about what type of content
you put on your channel and what they
can expect to see on there
sure the channel is mostly just me
playing MLB the Show the video game yeah
there's also a series where I play yes
where I play softball with a big group
of friends and uh we have a lot of fun
playing softball and other sports and
for some reason a lot of people like to
watch it
oh look at those giants guys out there
on the field I love it Oracle press I'm
a Dodger fan but I even played as Giants
in my most recent road to the show
series I was a six foot ten giant like a
literal
Junior was my character there I don't
think anyone on the Giants is actually
six foot ten but we've got Cardinals and
Brewers coming up on YouTube today if
the season ended today they would be
both be in the postseason do you think
the Cardinals have what it takes to take
out the Dodgers in a potential wild card
game
well they won 11 straight games so that
is terrifying and uh they might have
Wainwright on the mound who's been
pitching like a Cy Young again lately
but the Dodgers will probably have
Scherzer so hard to bet against the
Dodgers in that situation but the
Cardinal Cardinals also have a history
of beating the Dodgers in the postseason
so and one game Anything Can Happen
terrifying
um I just hope somehow the Dodgers can
eclipse the Giants or at least tie them
have a tiebreaker uh in these next 9-10
games so to close out the season yeah
who doesn't love 163 I mean as a Rockies
fan I had to experience that a few years
ago and they of course lost the Dodgers
had to go beat the Cubs and then they
say yeah it wasn't good against
Milwaukee and of course speaking of
Milwaukee the Brewers have the most
feared Bullpen of any team in the
postseason this year do you agree with
that statement
probably
um I think the Giants and the Rays
actually have the best numbers in the
bullpen but Williams and hater I would
not want to step in the Box against
either those guys super scary
um so in terms of fear yeah the Brewers
very scary
all right since we know you're a Dodgers
fan who do you think poses the biggest
threat to the Dodgers this postseason
gotta say the Giants they've been
basically the best team in baseball
almost all year Dodgers right behind
them
um that would be a very scary series
um playing the Giants probably gonna
have to go through them if we're going
to advance and I think we will advance
um I I always say the Dodgers are gonna
gonna win it all so I'm not I'm not too
scared but um yeah the Giants obviously
biggest threat well thank you for
admitting that I appreciate that I feel
like you guys started off slightly like
I suppose before the interview began but
now this is I mean this is a match made
in heaven friends BFFs forever
okay so before we let you go uh why
don't you go ahead and give us your
World Series prediction and uh who do
you think is going to end up winning
Dodgers and six over the Rays I'm
predicting an exact repeat of last year
luckily I was there for game six in
Texas last year and hopefully I'll be
there again for uh back-to-back World
Series titles for the Dodgers
I like it
chin you were very specific with said
prediction and
we really appreciated our time with you
Bobby we'll be sure to check out the
channel
all right thanks for having me
I like this guy Heidi's new BFF uh
speaking of BFFs Nolan Arenado looking
good there after leaving last night's
10-2 victory in Milwaukee with lower
back tightness of course it was because
he made an amazing catch there in foul
territory as the cards look for the
second four game sweep in Milwaukee and
franchise history Nolan Arenado might be
instrumental in accomplishing this feat
picks the click on the other side
and owls alive fastball to right and
Deep Get Up Get up get out of here and
go and he ripped it out of here Justin
Steele deals again a swinging a Drive
Right Center and Deep Get Up Get here
gone for Manny Pina Manny to left and
deep get up State Fair get out of here
and the Brewers have the lead and here
comes Caldwell for the chance to put the
Brewers on top here in the eight long in
the center field at base head Reyes will
score Kane will score
Colton long delivers in the clutch
swinging the drive into Right Center
this is trouble warning track at the
wall leaping and
well now it's wisdom now a base hit
could tie the game Harry comes
and this one is over
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
welcome back to the MLB game of the week
pregame show presented by Jim Beam
all right it's time now for picks to
click presented by bet mgn Adam
Wainwright has been fantastic lately for
the Cardinals should he be in the NLC
young consideration nobody's talking
about him he's not even on the board in
Vegas this is a great conversation he's
not even the top eight right but you
look at the competition it's just
stacked maybe it's not his year what
he's doing is impressive but look what's
going on in La you have shirts or you
have Bueller and then of course in
Philly Zach Willer who is coming off of
an amazing start and then of course oh
let's not forget who they're playing
here today that rotation is insane you
have Woodruff and burns So my answer is
I just rattle off all the other
contenders yeah it's it's not even a
soft no it's a hard no sorry we know I'm
impressed with what you're doing this
season but that's a no for me dog what
about you that's a no from her but I'm
gonna go yes he should at least be on
the board he's got the second most
innings in MLB behind Zach wheeler he's
nine and one with a 1.81 era over his
last 12 start the Cardinals have won 11
of 12. if that doesn't put you in the
conversation I'm not saying he should
win it I'm saying he should be in the
conversation and by the way LG I'm
wearing this box in Red Sox yellow
because I mean it's working for the Red
Sox they're going to keep Welling
wearing the yellow jerseys until they
lose the game I'm gonna wear it because
I think it's going to help me with my
picks to click what do you think I like
that I think you're on to something and
like if it's baseball dude like we're so
superstitious it's about as
superstitious as it gets I'm wearing my
pizza shoes yeah so if you want to talk
Ridiculousness if you're not
superstitious you're not baseball all
right uh can I put that on a bumper
sticker
it'll be our scene all right your second
pick to click who is your sleeper pick
to win the World Series okay so dude we
were talking about this in our
all-female broadcast and I'm going with
Toronto these kids are a lot of fun
especially after the All-Star break we
know what we're doing at the plate but
let's also look at what they're going to
have in the rotation they're either
gonna have to go through the Yankees or
or your Boston Red Sox for the Wild Card
race but they're going to have a little
guy by the name of Robbie Ray talk about
a young candidate yes for the AL and
then they're going to have burritos Ryu
and Alec Manoa one of the best rookie
pitchers in the game to back them up so
I could see them making a sneaky run yes
they're gonna have to run the gauntlet
in order to go through it yeah and to
get there but that's my sneaky pick to
win the World Series yeah they're gonna
have to start with the wild card game
likely on the road in Boston
I like to get into existence I like your
dedication to your pick earlier from
like two months ago I like that and hey
look I like Toronto in the World Series
I like them facing my San Francisco
Giants because growing up in Fresno
California nice little Central Valley
for Valley yes thank you my team was the
San Francisco Giants growing up and I
will say in spring training I didn't
even have the Giants pick to go to the
World Series but that's when they do
their best work who did when they do
their best work is when nobody's picking
that I love it they've been the best
team in baseball this year the Dodgers
have been on such a tear lately after
picking up Max Scherzer at the deadline
like that's not fair okay riches
um but yeah the Dodgers have been on
this great run they still can't catch
the Giants they're still two games back
I've got Giants you've got blue jays
it's going to be a Giants Blue Jays
World Series I'm here for it all right
number three pick to click it's over
under run scored in today's game the
over is eight runs under eight runs uh
minus 105 and minus 110 for the under
what do you got okay so I'm gonna take
the under all this talk about what
bueno's doing I think is a one eight one
era over the past month or so so this
guy's doing absolute work and oh by the
way on in the opposite Dugout they're
gonna have a guy by the name of Adrian
Hauser his last outing against these
guys was a shutout so I don't think
these guys are going to be doing a whole
lot at the plate and also we know these
afternoon games like you and I are still
trying to wake up because we normally
work late night yeah like these I don't
feel like everyone's gonna be firing on
all the cylinders especially in the
early Innings so I'm taking the Ender
yeah yeah I mean Milwaukee is a good
hitters park but those two pitchers
Adrian Hauser and Adam Wainwright you
can't count against them especially with
how good they've been lately and how's
your 233 ER right over his last seven
we've talked about what wayno's done
yeah so I'm taking the under as well all
right let's get to our poll question
who's gonna win the game basically who
has more fans watching our pickups
exactly
voting for their team and it looks like
we got more Cardinals fans they like the
12th straight win for St Louis over the
Brewers who I mean look the Brewers
magic number is three
so they win today they win tomorrow
they've locked up the division but uh
you guys have the Cardinals winning 70
so let's get an update from Cleveland
two hits and four hits and two hits and
two hits and three hits and two hits and
that ball is absolutely crushed
man oh man Luis Robert makes it a
two-nothing socks lead
one and two
that ball is annihilated did and another
chance to bring him home it's three
nothing socks it's a
in the air again right field Zimmer is
back at the track oh he did it again Tim
Anderson wants to do it all by his
Lonesome and the socks are pouring it on
on what looks more and more like clinch
day
I mean really if anyone's going to do it
all on their own it's going to be ta-7
and speaking of seven yeah that's a
football score right there seven nothing
only in the bottom of the third Heidi
like they were saying this could very
well be clinch missed there for the
Chicago White Sox it looks like they're
well on their way to securing that AL
Central division uh title really but I
mean it feels like they kind of had it
like back in July I mean really it's
been on cruise control but I think
they're going to be popping the bubbly
there in Cleveland or maybe having a
little nice round of Jim Beam right I I
could definitely have some Jim Beam with
that I I don't think it would sting as
badly as champagne does in the eyes so I
actually would be in favor of just
taking shots of Jim Beam instead of
doing the champagne let me take a look
at Adrian Hauser they're on the bump it
is the Brew Crew and the cards of cards
looking for the sweep out in Milwaukee
for our YouTube game of the week
presented by Jim Beam we'll get you out
to American Family field Scott Braun Tom
verducci and Brett Dolan on the call
[Music]
what a play
[Applause]
it's that fall feeling in the middle of
the country but Midwest baseball in the
National League is full of heat these
days they should have two playoff teams
coming from the division a power
pitching team along with the hottest
ball Club in the sport and today that
Talent is on a global stage this is the
MLB game of the week Live on YouTube
presented by Jim Beam the sizzling St
Louis Cardinals matchup with the
division leading Milwaukee Brewers to
conclude a four-gamer at American Family
field in Wisconsin and the National
League standings look like they're
forming into a playoff picture we still
have to decide the divisions in the East
and the west and Out West either the
Giants or the Dodgers are likely going
to match up with the flying Cardinals
the second Wild Card seat is theirs the
Brewers are sitting on a magic number
three to wear that division crown and
here we are ready to go in Wisconsin
Scott Braun along with Tom braducci and
wow the Cardinals have won 11 games in a
row did anyone see this coming no you
talk about being hot but then there's
hot at the right time and that's what
the Cardinals are doing if you want to
go back to September the 7th they had I
know you crunched the numbers on this
Scott a five percent playoff possibility
right things not looking good at all
well you talk about turning things
around in a hurry winning 13 of 14 since
then the best record of Major League
Baseball and how about lately 11 wins in
a row the first Cardinals team in
history to win 11 straight in September
this sort of reminds me of the 2007
Rockies that March to the postseason
they took it all the way to the World
Series right now you call it Cardinals
are the hottest team in baseball looking
really good in the Wild Card Standings
this is the difference this was not long
ago September 7th this is April or May
7th September 7th they were an
afterthought three and a half games back
teams to LEAP ahead up they run through
ball clubs like the Padres they've won
the first three in this series against
the Brewers they have a big three on
offense Coronado Goldschmidt and the guy
who's hitting number three it's not gold
Schmidt it's the iron that was Tyler
O'Neil I believe he's one of the most
improved players in all of baseball
batting average he has raised 109 points
that literally is the biggest increase
in baseball this year and in September
it's all coming together he's made a
mechanical adjustment at the plate we'll
talk about during the course of this
game but my goodness his goal of quality
outfielder and now a key middle of the
order hitter for the St Louis Cardinals
and you look all the statcast numbers
this guy is with the big boys when you
talk about hitting the ball hard Tyler
O'Neill right now is the one guy who's
got swing the hottest bat in the
Cardinal lineup
and you see the note on the bottom of
the screen the exit velocity has
increased second largest increase in
major league baseball this year and he's
a strong dude and it's showing now on
the field for the Brewers they're still
in control in a nice spot in the
National League central as their manager
Craig Council says they've just hit a
bump they've lost four games in a row
they have a big three though they're
starting rotation features Brandon
Woodruff Freddie Peralta and Corbin
Burns has a shot at winning a Cy Young
you're looking at the lowest starter era
in franchise history pretty much
organization wide they'll tell you this
might be one of our best teams ever but
it is definitely our best pitching staff
ever there's a ton of swing and Miss
from those three
but it's not just a big reaction
especially when you look at the second
half of the Season Eric Lauer has been
outstanding for them and so has the man
that you're going to see on the mound
this afternoon Adrian Hauser brings a
different style but it's effective yeah
just ask the St Louis Cardinals you see
his numbers here and this shutout the
last time he saw St Louis check out that
bottom line 23 outs on the Sinker the
most in a game since 2009 now he will
pound that Sinker into right-handed
hitters but what he did in that game
against St Louis was also backdooring so
when he controls both sides of the plate
with that turbo sinker that's when he's
putting up great numbers take a look
inside this start presented by statcast
3D powered by Google Cloud I'm waiting
on the Bevy of sinkers there they are 71
of those sinkers it's a pitch so good
Scott you can know it's coming but
hitters give up on it because it has so
much movement Adrian Hauser maybe not
the swing and Miss guy you've talked
about with the other starters but just
as effective in a different way with
that power Sinker and he'll have a solid
defense behind him both teams really
picking on defense we're looking forward
to that you're going to watch it on a
global stage today and of course it's
not going to be easy for the Brewers to
wipe away the bad losing taste because
Adam Wainwright is on the mound matching
up with a Brewers team that also has
seen a lot of Yadi Molina over the years
Brett Dolan is with us today and has
much more
thank you Scott well today our YouTube
audience is going to get to witness
something that Cardinal fans have seen
more than 300 times a starting battery
of Adam Wainwright and Yadier Molina
this relationship goes all the way back
to 2007. here is where it ranks Mickey
lolich Bill freehand worked together
more than 320 times Warren spawned red
Faber and Wainwright and Molina
obviously they've had great success
together Wainwright has sort of
reinvented himself over the last three
years but his earned run average with
Molina is almost a run a game better
with Yadi than any other catcher so they
have had a tremendous amount of success
now if this relationship continues into
the postseason one number to watch it'll
be the 15th time that there has been a
starting battery of Wainwright and
Molina for a Cardinals postseason game
we're going to step aside and come back
with our starting lineup it's our first
pitch from American Family field in
Milwaukee the Brewers and the Cardinals
it is our YouTube game of the week
[Music]
up the middle base hit Tommy Edmond will
score and it's two to nothing St Louis
Goldie drives in his 83rd
Goldsmith with a drive left field at the
wall God
home run number
25. and the pitch to Lindor is grounded
to the right side Goldie steps on the
bag and now they got a bit of run down
between the third and home Gotti chasing
him back they tag him out
and it's a double play oh my goodness
what a play by Goldsmith
and the 1-1 is whacked out to left over
to get it McNeil it's off the wall Tommy
Edmond to Third and that'll be a double
for Paul Goldschmidt
and a deep left at the wall gone Paul
Goldschmidt home run number 26.
Goldie hits it the other way against the
ship and here comes Tommy Edmond to
score Goldie is a triple away from the
cycle
Goldie base hit in the left Center Here
Comes Tommy Edmond he'll score one to
nothing as the Cardinals strike first
[Applause]
this is the MLB game of the week Live on
YouTube presented by Jim Beam today
Scott Brown Tom berducci and Brett Dolan
minutes away from first pitch in
Milwaukee the Cardinals taking on the
first place Brewers and the games we
share on MLB's YouTube channel are free
for everyone tell your friends
youtube.com MLB loaded with unique
features mic'd up players Dugout
interviews player of the game Trophy and
our latest feature puts the audio in
your hands you can personalize your
listening experience with multi-track
audio you can hear the home or the radic
road radio call we're gonna run through
a step-by-step multi-track audio
tutorial coming up for you if you're new
to the party
well Mike silt I promise you with
smiling more so than what you're looking
at right now when we chatted with him
today
that's Game Face his team has won 11 in
a row
sitting pretty in that second Wild Card
seat and matching up against Adrian
Hauser and the Milwaukee Brewers today
Hauser in his fifth Big League season 28
years old his era in the three and a
half range not as much swing and miss
you better have the defense behind you
quite alert this afternoon absolutely
because we're talking about one of the
best sinkers in the game and it's a true
power sinker
mid 90s with tremendous movement
you can see his numbers against St Louis
this season 14 Innings no earned runs
and that includes three weeks ago
against St Louis the first Brewers
complete Game shutout since 2014. let's
get to the pitcher breakdown presented
by Jim Beam what is Adrian Hauser all
about well he almost beat the Cardinals
last time with that turbo Sinker I mean
he does throw the pitches but really he
can beat you with that one pitch it's so
good normally you think about swings and
misses to try to follow how effective a
pitcher is with Hauser it's the called
strike so keep an eye on how many called
strikes he gets against the Cardinals
again that's because of the super
movement on that sinker
and a cardinal confounder 14 Innings
against St Louis this year no earned
runs allowed
third try for that Cardinals lineup
which is really clicking right now and
it is going to start with Tommy Edmond
their everyday lead off man all of the
regulars are in there today Day game
after a night contest when you're
feeling good why not this starting nine
presented by Jim Beam the switch hitting
Edmund is followed by gold Schmidt who's
hitting 350 during this 11-game win
streak Tyler O'Neal in a nice position
between Goldie and aronado the rookie
switch hitting Dylan Carlson Yadi Molina
back in there again today edmundo Sosa
has taken over at shortstop for St Louis
Harrison Bader is out in center and Adam
Wainwright is on the mound and hitting
ninth today for the Cardinals
roof is closed there is rain expected in
the forecast nice day though here in
Milwaukee
little breeze when we're heading in low
60s with the temp Edmond best in
baseball and doubles 41 of them this
season and he'll lead the way and we are
underway on YouTube
Hazard misses low
Cardinals matching up with Milwaukee St
Louis at 82 and 69 on the year going for
a 12th consecutive w
first 11 in a row since 2001.
it's fouled off to the right side oh one
was Albert Pujols rookie season
well again I think when you put together
a win streak at this time of year
looking ahead to October and certainly
the Cardinals are
that counts for a lot
first team in Cardinals history to have
an 11-game winning streak in September
they are 15-6 this month
and they're one away
from a 12 gamer that they put together
in 1982 11 and Counting
that's where Hauser likes to go back
door he's going in here
and he got him in on the hands
there's Kane to put away Edmond
[Applause]
[Music]
a bit different approach for the
Cardinals after want it back because I
mentioned strikes looking and that's
shutout against St Louis he had 31
called strikes tied for the most major
leagues this year in a single start
here's his arsenal we talk a lot about
the Sinker purple you'll see especially
to the left-handed hitters changeup I
think is a real good pitch you do have
to honor that I think that's the pitch
that the curveball against Goldschmidt
right here
Paul is a terrific fastball hitter
he did some damage yesterday
433 feet on a two-run blast that went to
the Miller Lite deck in left center
field it's a long ways
he's a fan of this ballpark for years
there it is
right in the front row of baseball went
to grab a beer
As Time turns on one
rias across for out number two
gold Glovers all over the field looking
at the defensive setup for Milwaukee
presented by Jim Beam
Yelich Kane and Wong have won the award
and then Bevy of cardinals will show you
in the next half inning
here's the big man
Tyler O'Neill
having quite the month
also the player of the week in the
National League wins the award for the
first time
good spot with the Sinker from Hauser
how do you pitch this guy lately
no that was it's a much difficult more
difficult question this year than last
year last year he had swing and Miss on
the high fastball in his game
but if you watch this setup at the plate
here he's done a couple of things he's
opened up his stance but you'll see he's
always had that little pump with his
hands to start a little rhythm going but
now what he's done is he's put a little
toe tap in that front toe will tap and
then go
what he told me was he really needed to
establish more rhythm with his lower
half he had it in his hands where he
dropped the bat back and forth on the
shoulder the most reminiscent of Albert
Pujols but that little toe tap that he
has there has got him on time
see how simple That Swing is
powerful simple swing you saw that last
night with the home run
cutter up and he didn't miss it
again this guy had a little bit of a
hole upstairs last year he's covered
that and a whole lot more
that was his 29th of the Season
yesterday career high good battle here
that pitch from yesterday was a cutter
very up that was well above the zone
he's popped eight in September
tied with Duvall for most in the
National League
Hauser shaking go back to that two
seamer
doesn't get the call
that's a great sequence because he
pounded O'Neill in the pitch before with
that two seamer opened up the outside
part of the plate that ball looks like
it's a mile away to O'Neill after the
inside two seamer just missed
the Cardinals have scored in the opening
inning in all three games in this series
but Hauser's one strike away that one
missed by a little more but it's been
all over the Zone Adrian Hauser Craig
Council and the Brewers with a magic
number of three to wrap up the division
it's the longest tenured manager in the
National League
Hauser to me is still much more
comfortable with that two seamer arm
side commands it much better
[Music]
just another good at bat in a series of
good at bats in September for Tyler
O'Neill
eight pitches mostly sinkers in this
matchup
payoff
challenged him with the Sinker and
Hauser comes out victorious in the first
three up three down the Brewers finally
silenced the Cardinals in the opening
inning
well there's a nasty little breaking
ball that's in there called strike three
Akio Badu is Peralta's first strikeout
victim of the night
got him off three pitches nasty and the
2-2 swung on and missed hey how about
that start three up three down three k
for Freddie Peralta so here's Victor
Reyes
there's a call strike three Victor Reyes
but he's got it going Freddie Peralta my
goodness 4ks already
got him again same spot that's nasty
good fight to it going straight down one
two pitch got him Freddie Peralta
want to start back-to-back K's three up
three down fourth inning Peralta with
six strikeouts through four and a swing
and a miss he put it right by him
seven Kings for fastball Freddie
swing and a miss he struck him out
number eight for Freddie Peralta here's
a 2-2 got him
went upstairs again and picks up
strikeout number nine
[Music]
former longtime Cardinal Colton Wong's
going to start things off for the
Brewers beginning nine presented by Jim
Beam Adonis Yelich in the free spot
today Escobar will clean up Maria's
Tyrone Taylor back in for another start
in this series Lorenzo Kane now starting
on back-to-back days opinion will catch
and Hauser in the nine spot you can see
for Yelich great numbers against St
Louis it's been a down season for him
offensively we'll dig into it in a bit
but on the mound is the 40 year old like
a fine wine gotta use the praise Tom
he's 40 but he gets better with eight
she's a three-time All-Star and he is
dealing in the second half of the season
I mean look at the Innings that really
jumps out to me getting over 200 today
most likely
pretty good for a 40 year old
how about that last line
1999 career strikeouts major Milestone
should be popping up for him this
afternoon
he's pitched through the sixth inning in
each of his last 13 starts you just
don't see that very often these days
as starters keep going shorter and
shorter here's first pitch from
Wainwright classic
Wong was a cardinal from 2013 up through
last season
makes contact through the right side
base hit
Brewers have their lead off man aboard
A Little Gym beam breakdown of Adam
wainwright's greatness this year what
does it look like well to me the
foundation is a classic combination
talking about the Sinker cutter combo
the pitch works both those pitches work
in different directions but he still
relies on Good Old Uncle Charlie that
big curveball when the pitch you throw
the most on a Full Count is a curveball
you know you've got a great one and you
better get him early if you break the
game into thirds wainwright's era gets
better in the middle third and better
even late third in the last third so
early in the game is when he's most
vulnerable
bumps the strike to adamus
one of the better trades we've seen in
years
he's back from the injured list
a couple weeks
dealing with a left quad strain
Brewer's shortstop is on a tear makes
contact in the air to right
Dylan Carlson will measure it for out
number one
you mentioned it
signature curveball is there he uses it
a ton statcash 3D powered by Google
Cloud you really don't know what you're
getting in any count he'll do whatever
he wants yeah I think it's more about
location sequence really hasn't changed
that much over the years in terms of how
much he uses his pitches and change up
you'll see certain times the left-handed
hitters but the way he commands the ball
on the edges of the plate both in and
out and it'll throw that Sinker a little
elevated as well
now a meeting with Yelich first to check
on Wong
yellow Joe for eight in this series
7 for 24 lifetime against Wainwright
this has been their guy for years and
he's locked up long term
MVP candidate for years last year was
down season this year he's hit the
injured list a couple times for a back
issue also the covet IL at one point but
just hasn't looked the same
and right there I think has been the
biggest Achilles heel Christian Yelich a
lot of trouble with breaking pitches no
home runs
off-breaking pitches this year
the last full season 2019 he had 12.
there's a lot more rollover in his game
the ground ball rate has gone way up
this year
two balls and a strike but when you
mentioned the back it's got you know the
kind of injury that even when you're
back on the field it still has to be
some lingering effects I just don't see
the same explosiveness in the swing
especially lately
three hits in his last 34 bets he was an
MVP in 2018 runner-up in 2019.
fouled off right side but you're seeing
a ton of that the ground balls from
Christian Yelich which we saw early in
his career as a Marlin and then he
picked up some lift and all of a sudden
became a top three top five hitters in
Major League Baseball you can see 18-19
but a slip since then
right here this is classic Wainwright
where he's going in and out on Yelich
could go back to the curveball right
here
he did and it was a good pitch just a
better take
[Applause]
I mentioned at the top he won't find any
pitchers who the pitch they favor the
most in a full count is a curveball but
that is the case with Wainwright he'll
throw everything
but his curveball percentage actually
goes up 3-2 let's see if he tries to
double up here on Yelich
it would be fitting if his 2000k was a
call strike based on what we've seen
from him this year
Runners moving Yelich lifts it to left
O'Neal will jog over towards the line
and haul it in and Wong will Retreat
yeah I can't remember off the top my
head's got a pitcher who could command
the curb all the way that Wainwright
does because 3-2 you need to throw a
strike there
and he's able to throw curveballs for a
strike that are still tough to hit love
pitchers or curveball as a Chase pitch
they want to get you out out of the zone
he can certainly do that but when he has
to throw the curveball in the zone 3-2
he's got the confidence and to command
it the way most pitchers command a
fastball
we use the term paint often but not
usually with a curveball he can paint
his curveball
and now he's got Eduardo Escobar switch
hitting All-Star acquired by Milwaukee
game over from the Diamondbacks 27 home
runs this year
ice cold lately like many in the lineup
well if you think he's going to throw a
first pitch curveball it's not a bad
pitch for Wong to run on right here
Milwaukee in an offensive rut the last
week
tough zone so far today
Molina just said he thought that got
it's a plate
maybe admit that outside corner on the
sinker
but it was a ball in the top half of the
inning as well so hitters know what the
strike zone is right now
Juan let off with a single
you know that's going to be a miss
home plate umpire Carlos Torres today
live game commentaries flowing with the
YouTube creators daddy Dimmu TV Wayne
Wright might actually be father time
[Laughter]
apparently next year
will be his final season it's
technically going to be free agent I
think the Cardinals will figure things
out with him but
looks like he's got a lot left in the
tank
yeah absolutely once again you saw it
there 2-0 count gets back into the count
with the curveball
he said he uses his curveball in 12
different ways different grips but the
shape has been the same since he was 11
years old in Little League
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
ball and almost no other pitcher in the
game
would do that in this situation
yeah I mean he he's again he's capable
of throwing anything right here but back
to the sink or away after showing in
foreign
ER you're facing Wainwright it's a
challenge because you do have to honor
both sides of the plate
and a difference in velocity that's
Extreme as well
and again staying out of patterns no
matter what the count
a lot of pitchers now 3-2 you can lock
in on velocity location can't do either
against Wainwright
me
even the change Up's been a big
difference maker for him this year
doesn't use it a ton but
effective when he's gone to it Runners
on the move
we'll do it again
and that was the cutter right there
that was a good pitch for Escobar to hit
[Music]
just enough late movement to get off the
barrel
[Music]
yeah let's work the Full Count so does
Escobar Juan's running
another foul ball
[Music]
here's the mix
the only pitch you haven't seen yet is
the four scene fastball once in a while
who wants to show that to a hitter to
raise the eye level
that was tipped
Escobar
and the Brewers looking to crack the
scoreboard first Milwaukee's dropped
four in a row their longest losing skit
since mid-june when they dropped five
straight but then they won 13-14 after
that
yeah the offense has really dried up in
the last week
we're looking for any kind of a spark
and right here
Escobar is extending the at-bat waiting
on a mistake from Wainwright
there goes Juan Ball Four
nice battle there yeah it's called
winning it back yeah it felt awesome
tough 3-2 curveballs
and here's Arias back at Third Base
today after filling in its shortstop
yesterday for adamus
the Homer did game one of this series on
Monday against John Lester that was his
21st of the Season he's had a really
nice year at the plate
throwing issues on defense he's better
in spots besides shortstop
going after the first pitch he likes to
attack early
there it is since August 1st
Reyes is slugging north of 500.
[Music]
well you saw the aggressiveness that's
part of his DNA as a hitter and
Wainwright
is an expert at taking advantage of
hitter's aggressiveness
see if he tries to stretch the strike
zone right here
now that he's controlling the count with
first pitch strike
he likes to lean back
and then dig in it's so in two
I think he's stretching his back you
know like a good wake up stretch and
then I'm ready
yeah it's kind of a thing lately in
baseball you know
um Winker and Rizzo and get into it
Thomas does a little bit of this as well
you don't see as many hitters in today's
game in a super Crouch or hunched over
I think because of the high fastball
game hitters you see more
upright than in the past
kind of a reminder
keep the weight balanced stay tall in
the Box
they're making them work
22 pitches in this first inning from
Wainwright
I talked to the top of the array in the
first three Innings is 3.71
in the middle three 2.34
final three 1.73
Now's the Time
did he lay off yes he did
Don libka
and I think part of that Scout is when
you're pitcher like Adam Wainwright you
have so many pitches
and so many that rely on feel and touch
and Command right
it can take a little while to lock in
what's working today what the strike
zone is
let's get the feeling he's kind of
working his way through this inning if
he goes back to the curveball here two
strike count
take on the cutter
and another full boat
three Brewers in a row
working it to 3-2
pitching coach Mike Maddox
[Applause]
let's talk through it yeah this can also
be maybe changing signs you go long on
second base their former teammate has
now seen five pitches from second base
done a nice job just spitting on a
couple of pitches just off the plate
this is a situation if you're yachty you
go out there you say what do you want to
throw and when you go back to the plate
as a catcher now you don't have to put a
sign down you've just agreed on what the
pitch is
so if there's any thought to the runner
on second base maybe is getting the
sequence you're not going to get a sign
here or if you are you get a dummy sign
[Applause]
[Music]
they've already talked about the pitch
they know what he wants to throw
[Applause]
Wong singled Escobar walks
two adds two on and he walked another
bounce that one and loads up the bases
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
that's unusual to see Wainwright bounce
that curveball as you said on full
strike Full Count
so it's up to Tyrone Taylor
second start for him in this series he
has 10 home runs on the year added some
muscle this year and it's paying off
[Applause]
last pitch a little harder than normal
on the Sinker Queen right at 91. the
play sits 89.
see that grand slam for him in his
career exactly two months ago against
the White Sox
here at home
and he socks the 1-0 Deep left Center
and forget about it
Tyrone Taylor muscles up it's his second
grand slam of the season and the Brewers
hanged four on Wainwright in the first
Scotty was one pitch a cutter that did
nothing sat in the middle of the plate
but it really was the effect of the 26
pitches before that and the quality at
bats that the Brewers strung together
against Wainwright to get to that point
[Applause]
thank you
what a moment for Tyrone Taylor
now Lorenzo Kane with a spinner and
that's going to sit down the side
there's Carlson but the Brewers strike
big
Tyrone Taylor with his 11th home run of
the Season his second grand slam of the
year the 27 year old is third year in
The Bigs just came back a few days ago
he's got more pop in the bat this year
and it pays off the Brewers looking to
salvage a game in the series they're off
to a fine start
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
ATO
since September 8th they alone averaging
about four runs a game and Nolan hits it
a ton in the Deep left
[Applause]
rbi's number 100 and 101 and he does it
in style
two zip St Louis the first since Matt
Holliday with a hundred or more driven
in down here Molina is grounded into a
fielder's choice and struck out over two
tonight
[Applause]
bouncer through the hole left side Here
Comes O'Neill yellets his throw not in
time and the Cardinals have the lead
first two have been retired here in the
whole map of the sixth
in the air left Center there's Vayner
John Lester through six and if the
Cardinals can hold on it will be win
number 200 in his outstanding career so
Garcia gets the ninth inning for St
Louis
round ball right side Goldie there a
flip and win number 200 in the career of
John Lester
[Applause]
a Tyrone Taylor Grand Slam in the first
Milwaukee's up big and we're looking at
veteran pitchers that are likely
post-season bound Frankie Morton
Scherzer and Wainwright and to be in
this club you need to be at least 37
years old buenos the senior member
Hauser starts off Nolan aronado with a
pitch inside so our first YouTube poll
question is now live which veteran
picture of these four will be most
important to their team in October
Wayne Wright's on the list
who's Tops on your list among these four
who's making the biggest impact who's
most important listen I know he's
surrounded by Walker Bueller Reyes but
I'm still saying Max Scherzer the way
he's throwing a baseball the dobbis puts
away aronado what a second half for Max
Scherzer
I think it's some of the best baseball
of his career
what is it with these guys Wainwright I
know the blip
in the first inning but
he's been as good as ever since the
All-Star break
you know we're seeing what some of these
older pitchers too Scott the durability
this year
and maybe the you know the short season
last year the 60 Game season maybe that
plays more in the favor of the older
pitchers giving them a little bit of a
break in terms of workload
that Broadway to Dylan Carlson
and those are guys that at this point
know how to take care of their body and
prepare themselves
for a longer season coming off The
Abridged version in 2020.
yeah Wainwright really is old school he
loves taking the ball on the fifth day
four days of rest
fourth straight start doing that
we so commonly say oh every fifth day
it's actually every six at six yeah the
majority Starts Now pitchers have five
days of rest or more
Carlson's bat is all over the place on
the infield but it turns into a single
thank you
we'll take the knob with you to first
that's the turbo sinker
movement plus velocity
see it run away from Carlson
natural arm side movement
and a one out base runner for the
Redbirds
here's yachty
now you talk about old school
don't use those words load management
Molina
we're talking in September Day game
after a night game
he not only is in the lineup he was out
there early taking ground balls at
second base
only a couple of the extras for the
Cardinals took batting practice plus
Yadi was on the field taking practice
loves to play and there's another ground
ball from Hauser yeah pulled to Third
and easy for the Brewers to double him
up and sit down the side but you're
right Yadi is caught all but one of
Bueno starts and for that one he was on
the injured list he's out there
Cardinals have work to do as they Trail
for nothing we'll get back to the
Brewers side here's a ria is firing up
the 5-4-3 shut down inning for Adrian
Hauser
the Cardinals in the last five games
really have set the tone they've had 15
first inning runs in those five games
O'Neill sends it out to Center
Taylor with the catch Edmond with a tag
Cardinals with a lead here in the first
inning just mention how this team has
been scoring runs early figuring out
ways to get themselves on the board no
run through five oh we'll do it back on
the bound to start the six oh and two
here he comes and it's a cold strike
three Woodruff with 10 K's so a
runner-up Second Tommy Edmond Edmond
hits it the other way that's amazing
Here Comes new car back in safely
two-nothing St Louis two to one Cardinal
they're gonna intentionally walk Yelich
so that's going to load the bases wow
and put the winning run at second base
and it's going to be Pablo Reyes it is a
gutty move to put the winning run in
scoring position the 2-2 yeah
in one season the Cardinals have won 10
in a row
foreign
[Applause]
thank you
[Applause]
come on let's go let's go that a boy Cy
Young candidate Corbin Burns miked up
for us all day on YouTube and you know
how some guys would go I called that
it's documented audio proof go buy
yourself a lottery ticket now stay hot
Corbin Burns what a season for him
everything's clicking
and here comes the Brewers offense today
five runs in the first three against St
Louis four in the first inning thanks to
Tyrone Taylor with that grand slam smack
and now it's number eight hitter Manny
Pina
and another couple of good takes see
Wayne Wright on the edge of the Zone not
getting calls not getting swings
and for a game plan to be executed
correctly for a command pitcher like
Wainwright
who has two strikes now on Pina
don't you need
well that was called off the plate wow
nice
that was a tough one you don't see a
catcher turn around very often but I can
understand why yachty did yeah he
backhanded the ball but that got plenty
of plate a lot of play
3-1
it's a foul ball
that was a tough one though before two
pitches ago
sorry that's
one of those [ __ ] that I don't even
look at the umps call just kind of
assumed it was a strike
yeah it's more proof that umpires can be
influenced by catchers positioning how
they catch the ball
is that just locking in on the width of
the plate
another 3-2 count from a brewer bat
today
and connected into left
there's O'Neal
well when Adam Wainwright is right he
owns both sides of the plate but I call
the classic combination cutter will move
from right to left
same area but now the Sinker is going to
move left to right that's called carving
an x on that side of the plate now he
can do that on both sides of the plate
so as a hitter
you're not quite sure which way the ball
is going to move imagine this pitch is
coming at you is it going to go left
gonna go right and that's what he does
carves x's on both sides of the plate to
both right-handed and left-handed
hitters and rarely in the middle of the
plate but that's what happened on
Taylor's Home Run
that's right Matt Antonelli in the game
commentary
Antonelli baseball said that cutter just
sat there for him talking about Tyrone
Taylor's big at bat
by the way Adrian Hauser is not an auto
out either he has I guess
just throw him a change up 1-0
and then just walk behind the mountain
at a little conference with himself I
mean that was respect
throws very few changeups especially the
right-handed hitters
and the only thing I can think of is
if you're trying to incorporate another
pitch do you work it on a pitcher before
you get into the lineup again
see if you have it
that's
cleaned up by Edmund
now that works even better go right
after them with your Sinker right on the
hands
well Colton long is one of got that
trouble started from Wainwright the
first inning with that leadoff single
and that was after breaking ball and
that got Wainwright immediately in the
stretch
just one quality at bat after another
followed
just one ground ball out first time
through the order for Wainwright
no strikeouts today looking for the big
number two thousand
he have to get the ball in the plate
today on the edge is not good enough 50
50 balls are going to hitter's way
the better change up from Wainwright
along with yet another really good take
by Milwaukee hitter
there it is
I have some really nasty moving on the
cutter it's the best cutter he's thrown
so far
[Applause]
cut all the way across the plate
that was a good example of the
combination we just talked about
cutter sinker
pick your poison if you're the hitter
it's tough to guard against both those
pitchers in now could open up the plate
away
2-2
you can see him frustrated with his
curveball command exactly just doesn't
have it locked in yet a couple we've
seen bounced
that was just not tempting enough for
Wong another full count
Milwaukee is a very aggressive hitting
team there's a lot of swinging this in
the lineup
I'd say it's not a great offensive team
but certainly good enough with the
pitching staff they have
just as if they decided today you know
what we are going to grind today guys
nothing easy for Wainwright today very
few Chase swings
the game plan's working the zone is
tight
Brewers have four
Bolton Juan is still in there
oh you see the pitch count of 46. he's
probably throwing about 20 on a Full
Count trying to get the strikeout number
2000 in his career for 20 or 21 times
Wong socks it to right and Carlson will
line it up
[Applause]
recovery inning for Adam Wainwright he
sits down three in a row his Cardinals
bats have work to do after two it's four
nothing First Place Milwaukee
one on four St Louis and Tyler O'Neal
coming up
and Lewis and Tyler O'Neal coming up and
O'Neill jumps on it and a deep left two
nothing St Louis and yet again it's
Tyler O'Neal great speed on the bases
for Tommy Edmond
on 2-0 Edmund lifts it in the air deep
Right Center Kane back with the catch
both Runners tagging up and here comes
one here comes another
attack
speed kills two run score Samos one up
and one down four in a row now for
Michaelis Coronado giving Chase
no he holds on went over the tarp back
to the infield and a basket catch from
Nolan 8-2 St Louis Tommy Edmond to
second base and goalie hits it out to a
deep left how far and it's a 10-2 Saint
Louis Lee the Cardinals won out away
from their 11th consecutive win count
them up 11 straight for the St Louis
Cardinals
thank you
all right let's polish off our first
poll of the day on YouTube which veteran
picture is going to be most important to
their team in October and Tom's pick is
the winner Max Scherzer takes it over
Adam Wainwright both very solid
candidates
I get the feeling you don't agree with
me those guys or our audience here well
I don't have time now but only because
there's so much depth in that rotation
but if we have time later we can talk
about that matchup because those two
might go against each other in a wild
card game but right now our time is
devoted to Miles Michaelis our Jim Beam
Dugout interview miles thank you so much
for joining us today and also before I
say hello I just want to let all the
YouTube creators know questions for
Miles he'll answer them I'll hand pick
them but you know miles I got you we've
known each other for a while how you
doing today good to talk to you I'm good
it's um it's a good day I thought the
roof would be open because we got a
great weather day out there but uh you
know it's going to be a good day we
talked about that a lot before this game
began I did hear that there is
precipitation in the forecast that
apparently is legit because I'm with you
when I walked in today I was like this
is perfect baseball weather it doesn't
take them long to close the close the
roof here
they could have waited it out I think
I'm with you Tom you want to see it open
today was open during BP it looked
gorgeous I'm a little disappointed but
yes there is apparently right around now
apparently
rain in the forecast there is a
strikeout for Hauser of edmundo Sosa
went away here in the third okay so
let's dive into it miles first off
congrats great game yesterday thank you
seven strong for your Cardinals in a
10-2 win what is working well for you
right now as you're hitting a group
really the last couple starts I've
watched have been fantastic
um just location just keeping the ball
down if I can keep all my stuff down and
get some ground balls and let this
defense work makes my speeds up keep
guys off balance kind of pitching
one-on-one not a whole lot of Secrets
there uh we got a great defense and if I
can you know keep the contact weak we're
gonna make those plays we're gonna get a
lot of outs
yeah I'm glad you brought the files
because I think the Cardinal defense one
of the best in baseball give me a window
into how a pitcher thinks out there
because your staff generally
I would say I don't say pitch to contact
but not as much swing and miss and say
Milwaukee so give me a window into a
philosophy you're on the mound the
defense behind you
um
I'm trying to get outs with with the
first pitch I mean so many guys now
uh you look around the league you know
they're they're trying to get their a
swing off ASAP you make a good pitch
early you can get a lot of quick outs
um and go deeper into games you know you
see a lot of guys you know five innings
hundred pitches 10 strikeouts I'd rather
go you know six seven or eight on 90
something with like you know just a
handful of strikeouts if I can get
deeper into the game uh you know take
take some of the load off of our Bullpen
and
and go Beat It Out Vader can move but
the following is inside it was close did
they challenge it or just leave it alone
what do you think
sometimes I can't tell from all the
overhanded Dugout we're looking at it
though we're looking into it let's see
under investigation
there is charge looks like they got him
but we'll take another look
just barely
one more peek
there by step
there's two yeah
let me sneak in a few questions from our
YouTube creators today oh fastball
coming at you right right away here
Austin hello miles what inspired that
epic mustache oh
you know you ever seen the movie Mr
Baseball Tom Selleck's got a great
mustache in that
um oh that hurt
um that didn't look good no catchers
catchers take a beating um I just think
it's a good baseball look you know good
classic classic Baseball look when I go
home for the off season I shave it and
then it's just I'm just regular miles I
guess you know during the season it's a
good baseball look it helps with the you
know the on-field kind of persona you
know to kind of you know separate your
your baseball from your your regular
self I guess if you're trying to Hype
yourself up and and kind of play into
you know what your job is what you're
doing so that's I like the mustache good
baseball look the fans seem to like it
so I just roll with it I love it no I
agree yeah you have your season versus
your off season look we're checking out
Manny Pina who is down it bounced right
off the left knee squarely off the
kneecap yeah
there's only one other catcher on the
roster for Milwaukee at this point in
the season some teams have three but
domar Narvaez we'll see if Pina can stay
in this game this tough guy I think
he'll be all right yeah catchers are all
tough man they get beat up I mean that's
not a thankless job but I don't think
they get enough credit for for being on
the the contact end of what people don't
consider a contact sport tell that to
any catcher not a contact sport this
guy's get beat up as bad as anybody
you're right and you work with Gotti and
Kisner yeah for so long and he is an
Iron Man yeah
it does look like Pina is going to shake
it off
all right let me get another one in
there the fireball review miles who wins
a foot race between you and the other
Cardinals pitchers
oh I like my chances with everybody
right now
um as soon as Flaherty comes back he he
scoots I got no chance there but I'm
glad I did mention that against against
Lester wayno and hap I think it's I
think it's really close half is pretty
quick I know you know Western Wayne are
a little bit older I like my chances
right now Woody's pretty quick too but
I'm a really confident guy probably
overconfident so I think I win yeah with
the five we have right now we win if
it's a longer distance Sprint like a
like a pole to pull I think I got that
easy or even like a timed mile I've got
some pretty good stamina built up are
you a runner
um
I like to exercise okay so I'm in pretty
good shape
kids uh run around after kids keep you
in shape
good point yeah
all right here's a guy I think he'd beat
in a race
the great Adam Wainwright at the plate
right now
are you amazed at what he's done this
year or
not really because
of what he's been bringing to the table
a broken bat is what he brings into a
club I mean you know I've I've had the
benefit of of seeing it since 2018 so
I'm not as surprised as most but you
know what he does is just incredible you
watch him day in day out his preparation
the way he takes care of his body uh his
preparation you know scouting reports
going into a game everything he does I
mean just you look up the word
professional in the dictionary you know
it's a picture of him and picture Yadi
right next to him that's right you're
fortunate you got some good teammates
with you miles Banks I wish it was
longer but a one two three and we'll
talk soon okay all right sounds good
thank you guys we appreciate it miles
Michael is with us for the Dugout
interview presented by Jim Beam we'll be
right back here on YouTube it's three
Brewers up for nothing
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
with a chance to put the Brewers on top
here in the evening
Reyes will score Kane will score
Colton Wong delivers in the clutch
swing on the drive into Right Center
this is trouble warning track at the
wall leaping and
well now it's wisdom now a base hit
could tie the game here he comes
struck him out swinging and this one is
over
[Applause]
[Music]
we'll get to the Brewers half of the
third inning and Willie Adamas will lead
off the frame and what's changed for him
since he changed uniforms oh yeah it's
different setup first of all I talked
about hitters being a little taller
certainly he's doing that the bat angle
is different
you see there was more up and down last
year and look at the angle of the
shoulders much more uphill last year
he's flattened out the swing a little
bit now I think lately
he's gotten a little back to being a
little bigger and a little more uphill
it's not his game he's made that
adjustment you'll see him in the Box
that lean back to remind yourself stay
taller in the setup get the hands into
the Zone a little higher and flatten out
the bat pass a little bit more those
adjustments have really worked wonders
for Adamas now listen he admitted he had
a lot of trouble hitting inside at the
trough in Saint Pete the laying there
changed a couple years ago he had a
tough time seeing the baseball that's
certainly a part of it but the
adjustments that he's made here with
Milwaukee have really made him a much
better hitter
and He adjusted their offense Milwaukee
was 21-23 and then he joined the party
and they have taken off
well here are the numbers here look at
the strikeout percentage the rate got
way down since he left temp Bay
reminds me years ago when the Giants
picked up Marco scudero remember that
yeah it was like nobody paid attention
to the deal and he wound up being a guy
who earned the nickname Blockbuster and
that's Willie Thomas the trade was made
and you're like okay they got adamus
nice
has there any been anybody more valuable
on the Brewers than Willie Thomas that's
the trade of the year I mean yes we you
can make a case for sure depending on
how Dodgers enter together and Turner
right but those are
Big Time names for years where
adamis really blossomed now pulls back
on his bunt attempt and takes one right
down the pipe from Wainwright here in
the third inning but
he's still young too he just turned 26
years old this month
that lean back there is more upright you
don't see many guys now bent over the
way he had been
going Arenado that's just easy for him
he's amazing over there at the Hot
Corner ground ball out for Wainwright
actually just the second of the game for
wayno
he's as good as there is throwing on the
Run watch is going to take an extra step
here
timing that clock in your head he knew
exactly how much time he had the way he
circled the baseball sets himself throws
a strike
most shortstops throw better on the Run
that's a third baseman throws better on
the Run eight time gold Glover who made
a ridiculous play Yesterday two actually
had to leave yesterday's game early with
some lower back tightness but he's back
in there today
[Music]
and now Christian Yelich
popular for what he's done
on the fields for the Brewers over the
years but you can make some extra
friends when you hook up 10 000 fans
with free tickets for this series and
that's what Yelich did he bought him he
said who wants them
they've sold out in five seconds when I
say sold out they were free
had to go grab them online
I love that gesture
it's a win for everyone to fill up the
park a little more too against your
rival
a definition of a franchise player right
who signed an extension rather than
waiting to hit the free agent Market
again
he said I want to be here and stay here
and very involved in the local community
you know you mentioned he's a 292 career
hitter gets Wainwright but I go by
recency and this year Wainwright has
kind of owned him he's got him out six
times on five different pitches and I
want you to pay attention not only to
the different pitches he or seen fast
before he's going to use twice to get
him but look at the location of all
these pigeons this is Adam at his best
changing speeds and living on the edges
of the plate inside and out
what do you see here Christian
he's got one to the left side and
aronado
will make it two down here in the third
a good example though when we look at
career numbers they've certainly faced
each other a lot but this year
especially Wainwright really going back
to last year as well the number is much
better against Christian Yelich
they have two ground ball outs in the
inning and here's Escobar
by the way do you know what hitter Adam
Wainwright has faced more than anybody
in his career
[Music]
for the sake of time speaking of the
Brewers
Brian broad yeah 102 times
recently officially retired right abroad
a ball and two strikes are we gonna get
the Milestone here Mac I didn't call it
yet here it is I'm coming in here the
chances I'm gonna try my best to be
Corbin Burns for one at bat yeah I do
about there strike three has been hard
to come by a lot of two strike pitches
1999 career strikeouts
today not there not on that call
yeah he can't believe it but you know
Carlos Torres has been consistent
and now here comes the 10th pitch
that Wainwright will throw on a Full
Count ten four count pitches
in the third inning 60 tosses into his
outing already today
Escobar walked first time around
and this time a Lazy Fly ball to Center
Vader's got it hitting over
so after the Grand Slam in the first
Wainwright has sat down six in a row in
Innings number two and three
the one-two pitch by Alex Reyes got him
strikes out the side in the eighth the
O2 pitch
strikes out the side here in the night
Reyes struck out the side of the eighth
Whitley follows him a ninth and the
Cardinals win it by the final of seven
to nothing
O'Neill with a Drive In The Deep Center
and gone Tyler O'Neill in New York the
2-2 O'Neill when they drive out to West
shot what a great moment
and Carlson sends a Fly ball out to deep
center it's at the wall
Grand Slam for the rookie oh what a
moment here in Bush
and Almanzo hits it out to deep right
nude bar back
large
oh
it's our fourth YouTube game
I think we've won every game we've been
on the YouTube game though
at least one a couple Tyler's got good
numbers against the old cards this year
they are got him yeah
[Applause]
that's true Corbin Bird's talking for us
today he's miked up on YouTube Hey we've
had quite a few Brewers games this year
and why not they're one of the best
teams in the sport
with a big three
I would say a big three in their
rotation and in their Bullpen we'll get
into it Tommy admin takes the first
pitch low from Adrian Hauser and yes his
Sinker has been mostly on point so far
today but the big three in the rotation
you have Burns you have Peralta and
Brandon Woodruff back into the bullpen
Devin Williams and Josh Hader but there
is also a young man who has emerged his
name is Jake cousins and would you call
him maybe the seventh inning guy for
Milwaukee and I know they're not
conventional in the way they do things
but he is probably their number three
reliever out Getters Scott yes
outkitters
the waiting Freight Council runs a game
I love it you know he squeezes every
outside of the ball game so yeah if you
order those guys I think cousins would
be the next in line behind Adrian
Williams
unbelievable slider I think hitters are
hitting about oh 90 against that slider
but if there's a point in the game
that looks like a swing point
he's going to bring in his best arm in
that situation Craig counsel does not
wait that includes using guys off the
bench there's cousins right there
you might see all of them today if this
holds up it's been a while since they
had a lead to protect late right you
don't want to get super swept by the
Cardinals they've dropped the first
three in this series including yesterday
one of their uglier losses 10-2 is the
largest margin of victory for the
Cardinals during their 11 wins in a row
2-2 on Edmund
that was a good changeup that he threw
in a better take by Edmund
another take
and a lead off base runner
all right so let's say on the Brewers
with our next poll question and if
you're new to the party let's get you
involved okay post it on your computer
screen mobile device however you're
watching here on YouTube we're looking
at four regular season MVP candidates
four mil walking Adam is Burns hater and
Woodruff nice and simple here boat
forests were towards the end of the year
this team is close to taking the
division Crown who is the regular season
Team MVP for Milwaukee this year
one on for Goldschmidt
there's a choice I don't think that's
simple either I think it's tough I think
it's really tough really tough
oh waiting a position player against
a starting pitcher a closer
gold Schmidt's bat is broken and he is
doubled up
well you want to know how well Hauser's
ball is moving right now
he's allowed one hit and he's broken
three bets
pretty good ratio you can talk all you
want about strikeouts of walk ratio they
hit the broken bat ratio is really good
right now
[Applause]
17 double plays behind Hauser this year
he leads the Milwaukee pitching staff
helps to have Colton Wong one of the
best in the biz at the Keystone
Tyler O'Neill
with the first pitch in foul ground it's
got a shot to Landon and glob oh it was
there for Eduardo Escobar
on his side of the netting couldn't get
to it well not a lot of experience over
there obviously so that's a difficult
play when you don't have a lot of reps
it's just a tough angle it's right over
your head
[Applause]
didn't realize he had more room right
there he says I got it but not really
he's playing first base for the first
time in The Bigs this year
have two strikes on Tyler O'Neill I mean
if this inning ends quick I'm gonna need
your answer as everyone's voting right
now on YouTube I know the pressure's on
but who's the MVP Marshall for the guys
who go out there and play every day so I
would say adopters I think he changed
his team because he got here everyday
shortstop that'd be my vote
I'm with you on that one it's
tough not to go Burns he's a Cy Young
candidate he's probably gonna finish one
or two but painter is the most difficult
believer to hit baseball yeah it's a
good call too
there it is Adrian Hauser picks up
another strikeout he's third of the day
he's in cruise control right now for
Milwaukee and it's a four-nothing lead
that will carry into the home fourth
foreign
[Music]
of 23 days in the summer of 2016 Alex
Reyes had a daughter and made his major
league debut he was on top of the world
until he wasn't and she just happened to
get like a little sick a little cold and
my daughter who wasn't even one at the
time she's got to put up this huge fight
that winter aleka started Cancer
Treatments a month later Reyes had Tommy
John's surgery it had been real real
easy to just kind of give up and
watching her fight for her life you know
it definitely helped me you know fight
for fight for my career Reyes found
Comfort by convincing himself that God
has a plan today that's become part of
his Instagram bio and his way of life it
just reminds me you know that there's
going to be obstacles that I'm gonna
have to overcome and and that they'll be
right at the end of the tunnel if God
did have a plan for Reyes it probably
looked a lot like today Reyes is now a
father of two a pitcher with perspective
not every situation is the worst
situation you know it's it's always it's
always something for you to learn and
and just to take whatever's whatever's
best from from The Learning Experience
four nothing Brewers bottom four and
we're all about options For You on
YouTube so if you're watching the game
of the week Live on YouTube your choice
of listening experience is available
let's walk through it you can click that
gear icon in your player choose audio
tracks you have the primary broadcast
with Tom myself and Brett Dolan or home
radio
Road radio all audio seamlessly
integrated on your favorite devices you
won't miss a minute of the action it's
all there for you can go back and forth
DJ and do whatever you want
we are at American Family fields for a
four nothing game thanks to Tyrone
Taylor's Grand Slam smack in the first
off Adam Wainwright how about Corbin
Burns radio is that available that's
true that's here that's on the primary
yeah stick with us and we'll give you a
lot of Corbin Burns content
he called that Tyrone Taylor Grand Slam
he said second deck kind of I mean it
went to that deck right above the
bullpen close enough
Taylor's on Deck
there's a curveball In the Zone from
Wainwright to urius this is interesting
because the last out the last inning
Wayne Right almost before the ball even
landed walked directly to Carlos Torres
and had a long conversation with him
about the strike zone
and he started this ending with two
pitches on the edges of the plate this
time got both called strikes Ellie
Molina was in on that conversation well
that's where the baseball goes for Aries
they play him straight up
[Music]
horizontally you're not getting that
today yeah that was a little low it's
close but again I give Milwaukee a lot
of credit earlier I talked about how
aggressive they are they actually do see
a lot of pitches they're aggressive in
the zone they see a lot of pitches
and let's as a batter and a pitcher all
you want is consistency with the strike
zone I think we've had that tonight
since that Taylor Grand Slam Wainwright
has sat down seven in a row
it's actually been now 22 batters
since wainwright's last strikeout I
think many are on the edge of their seat
waiting for the big number to emerge
2-2
that was a good case there too of these
guys that work together
Molina and Wainwright more than 300
starts and you saw Adam Shake Molina
yeah it happens
but you're not allowed well if you're a
young pitcher you're not but especially
when you have so many good options the
way Wainwright does that sent her away
it's a good example of the command off
today for Adam Wainwright as clearly on
the other side of the plate
he has built off that command he's
comfortable in his own skin he says it's
cool to say I'm almost or now 40 says
stinking years old and doing this and
that
welcome to the club
2 000 career strikeouts for Adam
Wainwright
and he has a seat next to Bob Gibson as
the only two pitchers in Cardinals
history to punch out 2K
and fittingly it was Uncle Charlie
the curveball
her career strikeout number two thousand
they probably could throw that
blindfolded
foreign
matchup with Taylor
first K of the day for Wainwright hits a
major Milestone and he's the ninth
player to reach 2 000 strikeouts with
only a single franchise
authenticate that
Taylor gets another good grip
oh wow Tyler
has another
what a day
is there a Home Run Cycle because he has
a grand slam and a solo shot in his
first two a B's five-nothing Milwaukee
uh just a great example of just waiting
on that curveball
just sat back flamewright left it up and
he absolutely hammered it you see the
exit velocity there at 103.
that was off Lorenzo Kane's foot looked
like it hurt
wow Tyrone Taylor with his second career
multi-homer game
and I mentioned
a few Innings ago it's taken him some
time to develop but the bat has been
impactful when he's been in there for
Milwaukee this year
yeah strikeout 2000 was on a terrific
curveball but down out of the zone
and that was just a hanger
sucker on pick back in 2012.
Tyrone Taylor
was on a five-game rehab as Simon
nursing an oblique injury AAA hit six
for 13 they said all right let's bring
that hotbat up to the big leagues
started on Tuesday he's back in the
starting lineup again today and he is
cashing in big all five RBIs are his
by the way that Grant Slammy it was only
the fourth allowed Adam wainwright's
career 178 plate appearances
basically
have a day by the fourth inning
and hey the Brewers are fine in the
standings but
you know Craig Council really wanted to
pick me up said hey about swinging the
bats well
one man is
staying up the middle it's gonna be a
tough play for Edmond can he get him and
Kate is safe
Edmonds very smooth at second did
everything he was supposed to do but
Kane legs out an infield hit but that
ball hit the base I think so I think it
did I didn't even think Evan had any
shot of getting Kane but he actually
made it close
that did
yeah getting back to Taylor you know I
was a little surprised that Avi Garcia
was not in the starting lineup today
and nice to have a great year for them
perfect Council explained you know he's
back hamstring and then barking on him a
little bit been a little judicious with
his playing time chance for Taylor to
get in there
first pitch Manny Pina and Edmond will
wait for it and that's going to be one
of the easier double plays to turn
there you go
but Tyrone Taylor strikes again well
Craig Council can say I meant to do that
I was feeling Tyrone Taylor in the
lineup
hanging curveball he deposits it into
left for his second home run of the day
making it five-nothing Brew Crew
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
seven to five Cubs bottom of the ninth
two down the Brewers have the bases
loaded and a 2-2 count on the hitter
here's the pitch swung on Fly ball left
field Brant Brown going back Brent Brown
drops the ball he drops the ball
three runs will score and the Brewers
have beaten the Cubs two on one out go
ahead and run it second
get off get
I hear it gone for Ryan
Brewers have the lead one ball two
strikes on Peterson
the Brewers have a magic number of one a
division title is right in front of them
[Music]
we've reached the fifth to Tyrone Taylor
homers it's five nothing Milwaukee and
it is time for our last Creator
Spotlight of the Year shining on Dodger
films who's been doing this for a long
time he has 1.33 million subscribers
about 700 million views on his videos
he's got merch a book he's a big deal on
YouTube runs a sports gaming channel in
real life softball videos too he began
this back in
2008. he is hanging out with everyone in
the live game commentary section Dodger
film say hello for us if you can Bobby
Crosby does a great job posting content
every day on YouTube which player is the
Brewers regular season MVP that's your
job right now if you're watching and now
the polls are officially closed and your
winner is Corbin Burns as aronado
smacked the first pitch down the line
foul 50 of the pie Corbin Burns wins it
were you surprised that adamus didn't
get more love
um maybe a little bit I haven't talked
about this it's they're all good choices
I think because Corbin Burns called
Taylor's Grand Slam
clinched him that pushed him over the
top yeah
see you can help us out with odds
courtesy of bet MGM
One RBI for Nolan Arenado
go for one with the ground out yeah if
he's going to lead off every time he
comes to the plate I'll take the under
yeah
did Homer in this series
two run shot in game one to left field
but you're right Adrian Hauser has faced
the minimum today with just one knock
for the Cardinals that's gobbled up by
Arias
and there's one more out turned by
Adrian Hauser who is having a
magnificent afternoon yeah what else is
new against the Cardinals right now 18
Innings no runs earned runs allowed to
the St Louis lineup keeping the ball on
the ground he's throwing ground balls
and he's blowing up bats that gives you
an idea
velocity and the movement on that two
seamer
the Brewers love him as a losing streak
stopper potentially if he can keep
things rolling four and a third three
strikeouts and bat companies love Adrian
keep them in business sell those bats
well listen the Sinker is designed to
really to pitch the contact right it's
not truly a swing and Miss pitch can be
you saw you got to deal with one of
those but generally the ball's gonna be
in play and generally you'll see a
higher batting average against singers
sinkers than a lot of pitches but
actually today's game Scott these are
the two toughest sinkers to hit
Carlson gets a hold of one into right
field and that is a fair ball and he's
heading for two and now heading for
three Dylan Carlson on the run and he's
in there with a one out triple
[Applause]
yeah that might have been the slider
that just kind of hung in there and
kind of down and into Carlson's swing
let's see out of the box right here and
you gotta love the effort you know
we had a really good conversation with
Mike show before this game because I
think the secret sauce if there is
something with St Louis why they're so
good so late year here
kind of the underreported aspects of
baseball their defense and their base
running
and I like the terminology he used he
called them the Special Teams of
baseball
you know people don't pay a lot of
attention to them oh that's classic
first pitch he loves to do that in an
RBI spot and he comes through the
Cardinals are on the board it's 5-1 yeah
not only swinging first pitch Scott but
knowing how the defense is set up he's
gonna pitch me away there I'm just gonna
serve it out to right field and take
what you give me
if you watch this guy take batting
practice his first round of batting
practice is just like this
abbreviated swing slap it the other way
there's a lot of RBIs to be had that way
[Applause]
18 innings for Hauser against the
Cardinals this year first earned run
given up
and we're on to edmundo Sosa
only 55 pitches so far today has been
economical
they got him
Danny Pina is doing just fine
heads up play to catch yachty that's
what yachty usually does he's like wait
you can't do that to me
a great heads up play and yeah he just
got burned got a little too much of a
secondary lead here
it really thought maybe he was getting
away but it didn't
oh and that hits 07.
this guy gets hit by a lot of pitches
he's got more hit by pitches in his
career than unintentional walks
that he does stand close to the plate
but this one
no chance of getting out of the way
it's just like an arm side two seamer
they just kept
targeting him
16th time this year
an HBP for Sosa
some guys just have magnets
where it seems that way yeah Mark Hannah
that one is that way
we saw him last week on YouTube and yeah
stands close but sometimes
seems to be that a pitch that gets away
is against the same guy on a ball club
and it's so so for the Cardinals
that's the pickoff
just that little secondary read there
that's enough to get him it's not quick
enough to get back
what do you think of the footwork there
Dancing with the Stars you get them on
the next episode The yachty said one
more season for me and then maybe 2023
laughs
president of baseball operations John
mizayla recently locked up that deal
with Yadi for next year he said it was
one of the easiest contract extensions
they've ever put together five minutes
or less to seal the deal yeah he's back
on a one-year contract for one more
season
that's downstairs to Vader
and Kim warming up
thank you
wainwright's in the on Deck Circle
have two strikes on Vader Kim is warming
up because if it gets to Wayne right
he's not going to take the Advent
[Music]
the rule of thumb in baseball used to be
in the National League if you're
trailing as a pitcher you're not getting
your third at bat
it's become almost a second of bat is
now in Jeopardy from trailing
leashes are shorter these days
tight take by Bader
well 5-1 Full Count two outs
you know what's coming here turbo Sinker
time and it should be on the inside part
of the plate
it is a money pitch especially to
right-handed hitters
Sinker down and in strike gas ground
balls
it's been on a great run with that pitch
a good job by Vayner to foul It Off
Dosa was moving
[Music]
three two count Hauser's gonna throw a
fastball about 70 percent of the time
[Music]
but again you know the Cardinals are
looking at him third time this year
they've seen a ton of those two seamers
It's just tough to square up because of
the movement
that actually wound up out of the zone
runner's going Vader contact drops one
into center field and Sosa will move
from first to Third
they're on the corners with two outs in
the fifth and that's going to be the end
of the day for Adam Wainwright after the
Bader single
we'll have a pinch hitter here in Matt
Carpenter
yeah I think he won the at that with the
previous pitch
this one's got much more of the plate
this two seamer the one inside really is
the one Vader fought off to get to that
one
nice job
and now we have the obligatory Mound
visits because there's a pinch hitter I
we really do need to fix this rule
because these do not count towards the
official limit of five Mound visits
anytime a pinch hitter comes up
[Music]
and inevitably it does bring out
pitching coach
why doesn't it count I don't know I
should he spent an hour before the game
going over the other team's hitters you
know Matt Carpenter is the Lefty bat Off
the Bench
I'm gonna put that down to some
off-season homework we'll work on that
okay in the meantime this copyrighted
telecast is presented by authority of
the office of the commissioner of
baseball and may not be reproduced or
re-transmitted in any form in the
accounts and descriptions if this game
may not be disseminated without Express
written consent
back to the action
Hauser versus Carpenter
carp has a pinch hitter this year
just a buck 54 you can see he's 175 on
the year it's been
it's been a down season for the longtime
Cardinal he's patient but most pitch
headers like to swing at the first
fastball they see
there's the curveball good take
[Music]
Carpenters two for his last 34.
do you know one of those knocks came in
wainwright's last start when he was
replaced
was back at home
Carpenter came through with a double
[Applause]
it's interesting the way they defend
Carpenter because we're so used to that
saying that extreme overshift
it's a Deadpool hitter not Milwaukee
and they've really adjusted their
defensive philosophy they
went from fifth in the major leagues and
shifting last year to 29th this year
part of that is because the pitchers
like Hauser
Craig Council was explaining to us that
the Sinker again designed to get contact
often beat contact shifts are designed
to defend hard hit baseballs
and a guy like Hauser with his Sinker
and movement is going to get a lot of
softly hit baseballs so the need for a
shift is not as prevalent
the Brewers have dialed back a lot on
their shifts and actually they're a
better defensive team this year because
of it
two balls in the strike to Carpenter
hey you don't see that every day a team
that's
a quote analytical
the way that they operate the slugging
percentage you'll add on sinkers Bueno
by far the best then Hauser in the two
spot
it helps to have Colton Wong on the
right side
yeah what's interesting the other guys
all throw mid 90s Wainwright 89.
it's a lot harder to do to depress
slugging with your sinkers only 89.
workout for him today
yeah that's what makes Adam Wainwright
so amazing this year it was
his shortest outing since May 15th he's
replaced here by Carpenter just four
innings for Wainwright today
[Applause]
his team down four big spot for
Carpenter
the three-time All-Star with Sosa in
third
Vader at a single
just saw Pina go out
put some new defensive signals and just
in case Bader wants to run here at first
base
three hits and a run in for the
Cardinals in the fifth
that's going to go to the seats
it's not a bad idea to run Vader at
first base but I think Pena would throw
down a second
there are times a lot of times with a
left-handed here up there that take
advantage of this and maybe get a bag on
a two-strike situation first and third
but I think the Brewers are defending
the skull on base here
opinion is an elite defender in
basically every way
[Applause]
framing going after Runners here we go
Carpenter now is a full count
well he'll be running now the reason I
say with left-handed hitter we have the
third baseman playing so far away from
third base the run run third can get a
much larger jump at third much larger
lead so if you do throw down and don't
get the runner at second
it could cost you a run
but now with Full Count two outs haters
off and running
once again shouldn't be a mystery what's
coming here
there's the line for Carpenter against
Hauser
successful twice also four strikeouts
3-2 Rutter's moving that's Ball Four
Matt Carpenter will head to First and
the Cardinals load up the bases back to
the top of the order in Tommy Edmond
I'll say this about Adrian Hauser's
progression in the past
he would cruise and then get bit by one
wobbly inning that actually happened to
him last start
four ratings seven hits five runs
against the Cubs and most of that damage
came in the fourth inning against the
ball Club
and so this is what I mean about the way
Creek Council manages a game
game gets starts to get a little bit
wobbly you have no such thing as a
seventh inning guy
who's my best arm other than my closer
to get out of a jam
and right now if he needs it it'll be
cousins
Chris hook has options
and they provide very unique looks I
mean the variety an Eclectic Bullpen is
what it's all about these days and
that's certainly what you're looking at
how different is Suitor versus
Strickland's box Burgers arm angle and
then Williams and his change up hater in
the fire from the left side
they're all available
[Applause]
Edmund flew out in the first pre-pass in
the fourth
Hauser had faced the minimum up until
this inning
another high pitch that Tommy Edmond
can't lay off
he's really good with two strikes though
and apparently with the bases loaded
seven for 17 in his life
go after those swings I think you have
to stay with the elevated fastball right
here
just a little bit higher
popped him up
it's for rias
the Cardinals strand the base is loaded
they do tack on one run their first of
the day Dylan Carlson scores on a yachty
Molina RBI it's 5-1 Milwaukee mid 5.
[Music]
[Applause]
this one is here
[Music]
a one-two new bar and he crushes one out
to deep right at the wall
pinch it two run bomb new with his first
career home run it looked like he
smashed it but you know how it goes it
ain't how far is how moody
foreign
Fly ball out to right new far back
three to nothing
and Almanzo hits it out to deep right
nude bar back and has it large suit
boy robs Alonso oh the rookie comes
through
Lars new bar oh my goodness I'm stunting
that Ball's not up in the seats I'm
stunned that he was in the right place
at the right time and maybe these guys
are having a little fun oh man
foreign
hey the Cardinals YouTube page is the
best place to go behind the scenes with
the St Louis Cardinals be sure to
subscribe so you never miss a video just
visit youtube.com Cardinals and listen
to MLB's podcast to hear the latest
analysis from insiders across the league
and exclusive in-depth interviews with
baseball's biggest stars subscribe now
at mlb.com podcasts
roof is closed today in Milwaukee
a little rain out there is what we heard
I haven't been outside now since I
ate nine in the morning Scott brought
Tom verducci Brett Dolan hanging out
with you on YouTube and ready for a new
picture for St Louis
Kim
in the game mostly a starter he's been a
relief pitcher lately his last two
appearances out of the bullpen he is
second on the team in Innings pitched
and he starts with a pitch down low to
Adrian Hauser proposing pitcher up for a
second time after a ground ball out
from him in the second
going right after him and Kim
last appeared
on September 14th against the Mets at
City Field picked up a save one inning
two unearned runs allowed 26 pitches but
he's made 21 starts this year
he's a strike throwing
uh fastball is actually a couple of
ticks up what it normally is out of the
rotation
sitting here at 93.
that's typically what would see from him
89.90
yeah the four seamer on the year is
clocked at an average of 89.
[Music]
the Brewers and their full counts today
four
leadoff walk to the pitcher
well let's go back to hausers of bat
against Evan here Bases Loaded two outs
looked like he was getting a little bit
wobbly and look what he does he goes
into his back pocket and says I'm not
just a two-seam guy I'm a four-seam guy
too and a great job by both Pina and
Hauser by reading the swings from
Edmonds and never getting off the four
seamer
I don't know how many times this year he
has thrown three consecutive four-seeing
fastballs
that's a case of reading the swings and
sticking with it there's no reason to go
to another pitch to set it up again just
stick with that pitch that's just
great baseball IQ by catcher pitcher
combo there are very few superstars who
set you up right
who act like they can't handle that
[ __ ] and then say just kidding
there's a strike to Wong it's one and
one
again he's not going to throw that many
four seat fastballs of course the game
maybe a dozen
tripled up on it
in his biggest Jam
that was a tip off one's bat it's a ball
in two strikes
now two and two
to me that's Kim's best pitch that
slider right there
it's not a good take by Wong
[Music]
Brewers are just not going away today
Scott
[Music]
even though it's been a one-man show in
Tyrone Taylor these are
feel like playoff at bats not giving
away a pitch
[Music]
Kim got Wong
so there's one here in the fifth
let's bring in Brett for a little more
on one of the base coaches Jason lane
third base coach for the Milwaukee
Brewers Brett what do you know about it
yeah Scott caught up with my old pal
Chase in lane today now his name may
have popped on your television screen
this week when Anthony goes got back to
the big leagues five years after being a
position player as a pitcher it was a
similar path for Lane remember he was a
starting outfielder on a World Series
team in Houston in 2005 a couple of
years later he was in the miners
couldn't get back in 2012 he switched to
being a left-handed pitcher went to
independent baseball with the Sugarland
Skeeter
as base hit for Willie Adamas and it
moves Hauser over to Second so
he was uh with the Sugarland Skeeters in
2014 he got called up by the Padres went
10 in the third Innings gave up just one
run he was 37 years old he was seven
years removed from the big leagues so I
would say maybe we don't appreciate how
tough it is to get to the majors we all
should appreciate how tough it is to get
back five seven years later as a pitcher
and hey he's been busier today in that
third base coaches box as well
and you know who I immediately think of
that we saw come back the other day
after we watch it Thomas smoke one past
short
know who you are going to say who popped
back up in the big leagues after
spending some time as an outfielder a
Speedster he is now a bullpen member on
Cleveland Anthony ghosts firing 100 plus
regularly
not pick it as a position player
full-time and then took a lot of time to
develop as a pitcher and do his own
version of a Jason Lane thing
Jason went into independent ball
that's dedication yeah about working
your way up
but you know what he's got pressure on
him right now because the pitcher is on
second base
yeah man it's Third Base coaches they
sweated out the pitcher out there you
can't take any chances
[Music]
yelich's Hit List in two trips today
he's got them set up for the slider
right here again Christians really
struggled on breaking pitches this year
and he's over his last 10. he actually
hit in the Five Spot on Monday for the
first time this season and the first
time
below Cleanup in the order since 2015.
it's back at three today
there you go Tom bus 0-1 yeah very slow
slow curveball but Christian you know
for to have no home runs off a breaking
pitch
this deep end was seized it's just hard
to fathom
when he's right he's got some of the
best balance I've seen at the plate
where you can't get him out on that
front foot on the breaking pitch
good take right there
I know we mentioned the back and you
know he says he's okay right now but the
players hurt aren't we usually looking
at the timing on a fastball versus off
speed
there could be a lot of things for me
it's more watching him move defensively
and I don't see the explosiveness that
first step quickness in the Outfield
[Music]
Hauser and Adam is on for Yelich
and now make it three on for Milwaukee
they loaded up for Escobar Kim just
couldn't execute a breaking pitch for a
strike tried three times couldn't do it
you had the guy set up for it
it's got to be really careful I always
look here in these situations Scott
struggling to throw a strike if you're
so anxious to get ahead get a ball in
the strike zone
and as a hitter
run around third less than two outs
you're looking to hit the ball in the
air
this is a dangerous pitch right here
you are not going to get a free strike
from Escobar here
the switch hitter
goes for the first pitch foul Eduardo
Escobar is one of the games best at
lifting the baseball his launch angle is
up there
so that was a good pitch it wasn't in
the middle of the plate
but you saw the case where the hitter
was ready
[Applause]
he walked and scored in the first flew
out to Center in the third
[Applause]
and now in the fifth flicking his chops
and now behind oh and two
[Applause]
[Music]
Eduardo Escobar just a couple of years
ago
at 35 home runs and 118 runs batted in
with Arizona
for base machine
cream backspin on the baseball from his
Bat when he's feeling good
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thought about it now one and two
he's also got his game face on right now
but he is one of the
I would say
most comedic Clubhouse presences in
baseball
that's got left to right Carlson will
make the grab Hauser will knock out
not a tough call for third base coach
Jason Lane to say hold up
there's two outs now in the fifth
that was right in that Medium Zone where
if it's an average base runner I agree
but no chance at all with the pitcher at
third base right here
[Applause]
Carlson does a nice job took his time
that's just the bluff all the way he's
never going on that ball
Luisa Reyes Brewers fans know
loves the bases loaded this year six for
13 in these spots
20 plus RBIs
just when the bags are loaded
him starts him off with a strike
when the Brewers were ice cold in the
first three in this series they were 11
for 90 in the first three games until
122 batting quit
what you saw right there is what they're
doing best today just
spitting at pitches out of the zone and
there's his lifetime with the bases
loaded that's as good as it gets that's
exceptional right there
I think with the bases load is about
understanding that the pitcher is the
one in trouble
make the pitcher come into the Zone
always important especially now
and a half swing for arronado
Kim extinguishes the threat without
giving up any damage base is left loaded
by Milwaukee after five the Brew Crew
hanging on to a 5-1 lead thanks to two
homers from Tyrone Taylor
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
up here
Kelly with a 1-2 and O'Donnell's with a
Fly ball here back in a deep right field
and it is good
William Thomas goes opposite field in
the ninth and the Brewers latest in
Colorado
[Applause]
one ball no strikes on Adamas swing and
a drive deep left field
William Thomas strikes again against the
Colorado Rockies and the Brewers come
back down four nothing
Adamas in the air right center balls hit
well marisnick on the Run
and he's up and out it's a grand slam
the first of the year for the Brewers
Willie and Thomas again and this
ballpark is lit up
foreign
we don't we don't have a guy there
this way
Corbin burns with his own play-by-play
of Eduardo Escobar's attempt to grab a
ball and foul grounds and came up empty
he's learning
he is I remember the time they made the
trade
it's like where is he gonna play
and they said well he could possibly
play first really hasn't played first
base before but you know David Stearns
and his crew said you know what he's a
good athlete
[Music]
we'll figure it out yeah it's gonna play
hitter not designated hitter hitter and
we'll find a spot
because he's capable of big Power
numbers another poll question coming at
you
play along we did it for the Brewers
we're fair right down the middle for you
okay the MVP regular season for the
Cardinals is arnato Goldsmith O'Neill or
Wainwright good luck
three hitters or a pitcher
and the poll is now open
and Tom verducci always has that
important job of helping the voters at
least by weighing in on his pick
I gotta tell you I'm not sure about this
this is a tough this is tougher than a
Milwaukee one
uh based on the quantity right you
really could go with any option here yes
yeah
I mean all those Innings Wainwright has
thrown he's over 200 now
yeah you know when you need them the
most he's done it down the stretch
Corner guys are just there every day
producing reliability defense base
running those two guys
see the brain churning as you're talking
through it
you know what I'm gonna go with Tyler
O'Neill
because when you think about what turn
this season around
I gotta start with O'Neill
it gives them three intimidating forces
and you kind of knew you had the other
two right and they have been as I said
reliable
O'Neill again highest batting average
Improvement in baseball top three and
sluggy percentage we've got Joey ohtani
Avi Garcia and Tyler O'Neill biggest
slugging percentage increase this year
gold Schmidt with a hard hit baseball
into left on an O2 count has himself a
single
he's one for three today O'Neill is
coming up
well Adrian Hauser has been fantastic
but
Brett Milwaukee had an historic day not
too long ago and they celebrated it
before the game they sure did it was
back on September 11th there was the
combined no-hitter in Cleveland Corbin
Burns Josh Hader as well as Narvaez the
catcher we're honored in front of the
hometown fans what a special night it's
the third time this year Cleveland have
been no hit of the nine in big leagues
this season
and that is a rias making a nice stop
with the glove and the throw the short
way is in time to erase Goldsmith take
the mic something and play but
nonetheless it was quite a night Burns
had 14 strikeouts hater had a pair 16
combined in that No-No but it was only
the second no hitter on Brewers history
you have to go back to 1987 for Juan
Diego so that was a special moment part
of a special season you're right
Burns knew it he wasn't going to get the
nine back then for that no no look at
Urias now he has arrows Galore this year
but it's it's on the arm
it's not with the glove the glove's been
great yeah great range right there and
gathered himself made a good throw to
second base
another ground ball out for Adrian
Hauser and that's his guy adamus came
over
Coronado rips one and Yelich runs it
down
Sweet Spot contacts but Christian Yelich
is there and left
two nice plays on defense from Milwaukee
[Applause]
well I mentioned his first step I didn't
think he has been moving as well he
certainly responded well the ball off
the bat good jump on this ball and ran
it down
assistant
Dylan Carlson's been the best bat today
for St Louis
a single and a triple
and what's next
just to finish the thought on Arias in
the Milwaukee coaching staff said he was
feeling the heat at shortstop in the
first half of the season they acquire
adamus he comes over and shows Arias
nothing but love it's been somewhat of a
mentor for him and he's handled Third
Base well
Carlson spits it to let and Yelich right
in front of the track
will end this inning
so after a lead-off pit for Goldschmidt
and some hard contact Adrian Hauser has
himself another scoreless frame and a
5-1 Edge heading into the bottom of the
inning
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I think now is the time to bring this to
you because all season long on the MLB
game of the week we've given you the
option you the power to vote who is the
player of the game who gets the trophy
who hangs out with us on the post game
show polling options coming later in the
game we'll hand out the hardware in the
post game show right after Cardinals
Brewers comes to a close and I say all
of this because stepping in to lead off
the home sixth is Tyrone Taylor with two
home runs in his pocket including a
Grand Slam in the first
have a day from
a Brewers bench player who gets the
start today because Avi Garcia is
getting off his feet
so is this kind of like the British Open
where the engraver is already
chiseling the guy's name into the trophy
now this one stayed at the park yeah he
flies out on the first pitch to right
I don't think he's here or she but it's
quick
it's engraved and then it's shipped and
Tyrone Taylor is in our minds the leader
of the pack for now statcast powered by
Google Cloud he did some damage to a
couple baseballs earlier today yeah two
Mistakes by Eminem
the other on the curveball and he didn't
miss either one
into that he knew it
32 Degree launch angle that was up there
for a while
[Applause]
now it's Kane but I mentioned earlier
it's taken Taylor some time he's 27
years old this is his third year in The
Bigs debuted in 2019.
and he was drafted back in 2012.
but the bat has really come along he
does a nice job in all three Outfield
spots for the team
a 2-1 on Kane he didn't go around but
Tyron Taylor is going to be on the
playoff roster and he might have some
big APS in October
thank you
balls and two strikes on Kane Kim
quickly with another delivery and he
Rings him up
[Applause]
[Music]
and Locane can't believe it but
yeah even with a tighter Strike Zone
today that's a strike
[Music]
a different pitch
yeah it wasn't that high but it did get
the play
[Music]
I thought it was low bottom of the Zone
but it's in there
Kim picks up his second strikeout today
here's Mandy pedia
well he's a warrior he took a foul tip
flush off the kneecap
[Music]
that's in the air to right Carlson on
the Move in the corner and it is a fair
ball
Pina picks up a double
he's had a hot month and that continues
all right really nice job taking this
ball the other way Carlson looked like
he might have had a chance for it but
just ran out of room
uh it's so important when you're hitting
eighth National League two outs
in this case picture behind you and
expect the Brewers to pinch hit right
here quick
let's say Al Garcia
so Abby will get an A B today
I'm sure Hauser would have gone back out
for another inning but in this case
looking for another run
as for Garcia to hit against the
left-hander
good day's work from Adrian Hauser
close the book 81 pitches Hauser with
six Innings one run
three strikeouts two offs
and he is pitching for an important spot
perhaps as the number four starter for
the Brewers maybe we see him make some
starts in October for Milwaukee we know
who the first three will be Lauer's been
great in the rotation as well
I think the way Craig Council runs
things in a series he would have Hauser
and the bullpen available for the first
couple of games
and then figure where you are when and
if you get to a game four
but he'd have no problem he needed
someone to get out of right-handed
hitter
middle innings
going to Hauser
flower's been great too
fits so well against St Louis this year
just one run in those three starts got a
good example today why he really is in
attack mode almost all the time
strike percentage excellent
controlling counts
running the baseball with a lot of
confidence lately
him versus Garcia
obvious two home runs in this series
he did miss some time
not an eye else did but lower back
spasms he came back on Monday and
homered in his first at-bat he's another
guy his powers played up this year I
think he's made some adjustments to get
more backspin on the baseball
for that Top Hand where it used to turn
over doesn't turn over through contact
[Applause]
weekly on the ground Edmond will handle
it well Garcia had been a cardinal
Crusher seven home runs in 12 games
against St Louis but this time Kim does
the trick and the sixth inning is over
still Milwaukee five St Louis one
it has never been done before in the
ALCS where a club has fallen behind in
the first two games and then come back
to Win It County Stadium was rocking
that night from a jam-packed County
Stadium the American League Championship
on the line
three to two got the bases loaded Cecil
Cooper hitting Cecil Cooper comes to the
plate with opportunity staring him in
the face Mr Cooper
one run home now
the Brewers lead 4-3 without question
the biggest moment in my life
[Applause]
and so it came down to a future Hall of
Famer against a newly christened closer
what a poetic way to reach the World
Series
[Applause]
thank you
MLB Originals season two is Live on
YouTube with new episodes every week see
your favorite players and learn more
about the game you love on youtube.com
MLB
and MLB celebrates Hispanic Heritage
Month by recognizing the contributions
made to our game by the Latino baseball
Community past and present follow at Las
mayores and at MLB and visit Las
mayores.com for full coverage
[Music]
some sunshine peeking in to a closed up
ballpark here at American Family field
and we're closing up our third poll
question the Cardinals regular season
MVP according to the people is Nolan
Arenado that's close yeah the new member
the big off-season ad for St Louis he
beats out goal do you finished fourth
Wainwright in the two spot and O'Neill
taking up 24 of the vote but aronado
solidifies the defense gives them
another aircraft carrier in the lineup
and
there's a new pitcher in the game for
Milwaukee some warm-up tosses from Jake
cousins but now
a meeting here and a conversation about
the glove Tom
as Jeff Nelson
called over great Council there
might be the color of the glove is it
too light yes
it is very light
typically you know you wouldn't see a
white glove I wouldn't say that's white
but it is I think
maybe it's so light that it may be a
distraction to a hitter
so the glove got ejected you're out of
here
you look too much like the baseball yeah
that'll work that's fine yeah good looks
a little smaller though doesn't it yeah
it's like an infielder's glove
how about Corbin Burns he's doing it all
wearing a bike equipment manager
there is an advantage if a baseball is
coming out of it like love to try and
catch a baseball
especially when you watch what dick
cousins has been doing lately the
Cardinals know
a little gamesmanship though Tom
I don't I wouldn't call gamesmanship I
mean it's certainly within your right as
of visiting any team you see a pitcher
out there with a glove that it just
looks a little funky why not we have
rules against those things so we're not
inventing anything
I just think this club looks a lot
smaller
oh the other thing is he's been using
apparently that other glove that was
just ejected all year right
he used it last night
[Music]
you know
something that seems little like that is
going to fire up the breweries
especially the pitching staff
and you've been rocking the same glove I
don't know if Jake is superstitious
either but I mean you want to stick with
what's working this year and he has made
a Big Time comeback and his career
starts off Molina with a ball tipped off
the bat
two nights ago that looks like the same
suspect
yeah the Cardinals were like you know
what this guy's too difficult to hit us
let's try a different glove and see if
anything something else works
but he's been through though Scott I
don't think changing gloves is going to
bother him
this guy was a 2017 20th round draft
pick at a pen by the Washington
Nationals
and two years later after a bunch of arm
injuries they released him
and he wanted to quit baseball
still a young man but
got beaten down by injuries more so than
ineffectiveness
and it was his family who basically said
now let's give it one more shot you'd
rather go out on Merit pitching poorly
where you don't have a job rather than
injuries holding you back
and one of the pieces of advice he got
was from his cousin appropriately enough
the Kirk Cousins
who basically said 20 years from now you
think you're going to look back and say
I wish I quit baseball sooner oh
and here he is
and again that whiff rate almost
entirely built on just a nasty slider
and that's why there is now a big three
in this bullpen
catches the corner
three and two to Molina well you see
where cousin sets up on the rubber the
far Third Base side so a right-handed
here that ball seems to be coming from
behind your back
and he actually steps like he's going to
throw into the Cardinals dugout
96 challenged Molina and wins it
I mean that's just filthy but especially
right-handed hitters because of the
angle that he creates Jake's a tall guy
but creating that angle by the way he
positions himself on the Rubber and the
way he steps
and that's 96 by them
now you see on the mound there most of
the footprints on the mound are in
direct line to home plate
Jake steps in a place that's fresh dirt
nobody's stepping as far to the first
base side of that downhill Mound as he
does
at Mundo Sosa first pitch takes a hop
pass to Damas and in the left
a one-out single for the Cardinals
shortstop
that Linda was bothered by the angle at
all
[Music]
got the first pitch slider didn't wait
around
you see where Thomas is playing he's on
the grass
[Applause]
picture divots
classy guy over there at Short
Harris invader's turn with one on
I should add that when Jake did decide
to keep pitching he had to go to
Independent ball
the Schomburg Boomers of the Frontier
League
was the way back to the big leagues
All Things Considered he got here
quickly
what a path and
what a motivational speaker to have NFL
quarterback as your cousin
setting you up with some big league
advice
stick with it it worked
his eras in the ones
in his rookie season 27 years old
two balls and a strike to Harrison Vader
well it hasn't happened yet but the
Brewers are or should be on their way to
clinching their second division title in
the past four years
they have secured a fourth consecutive
postseason right Council
Craig Tober
known by some around here
one of the best in-game
strategists
in this sport
a base on balls for Harrison Vader
let me take you back to yesterday
because you don't see this every day but
you appreciate it and it goes to what
you're talking about with the Cardinals
face running
this is hard hit off the bat of O'Neill
great catch by Lorenzo Kane but he falls
the toss to Garcia to try and get Vader
that wait not third but second he scores
on a Sac fly it's a two RBI Sac fly for
the Cardinals yesterday and it's classic
St Louis Cardinals offense
special teams baseball defensive base
running
doesn't get a lot of attention but
this Cardinal team is an excellent base
running team Tommy Edmonds the best in
baseball going first to third you just
saw Bader there smart from second on a
Fly ball I look at Goldschmidt and
aronado two of your Superstar players
who are fundamentally expert base
runners you watch the way they react
when the ball's hit the way they cut the
corners on the bases textbook
this is something where you have to have
you have to pay attention to base
running it has to be a priority it is
spring training it is every day with St
Louis
Cardinals are going to have large new
bar pin [ __ ]
Brad pile on for us Tom I love that line
too as far as the Special Teams of
baseball defense and base running and
show it went on to say when you have
guys who love to compete they want to be
good at the little things but the other
line I loved was keep the routines fresh
I thought the routines were the routines
but they try and sprinkle them up but my
goodness these guys love to play the
game and it certainly shows
there are some excellent wise example
centers too now Wainwright Molina if
they're out there if Molina's out there
day after a night game taking ground
balls at second
on the field early Scott before this
word existed I learned a long time about
I'll go about the power of influencers
not just on YouTube but in baseball and
I go back to the Minnesota Twins 80s and
Kirby Puckett ran hard 90 feet every
single time best player in the team
you're the 25th guy you better be doing
the same thing the best player in the
team is doing and that happens here in
St Louis as well with Arenado and
Goldschmidt
it just becomes a priority and I don't
even think Mike Shield has to remind his
players about the importance of Base
rank at this point as part of their DNA
this bunch is locked into the game on a
daily basis they've won 11 in a row
that streaks out the line today it's a
big chance for them to capitalize you
figure Devin Williams in the eighth Josh
Hader in the ninth
that's been the script this year
Scott if you look in there Dugout you
see how many guys are on the front row
I'd love to see that the guys on the
railing
5-1 ball game they're in it
and another walk
[Applause]
bases full of cardinals with just one
out in the seventh
Here Comes Craig Council
that'll be Brad Boxberger
well the inning started off nicely for
Jay cousins
he fooled Yadi Molina
Sosa went after the first pitch for his
single and then back-to-back walks and
the day is done for the Brewers rookie
the veteran Brad Boxberger former closer
he's going to enter the mix big spot
here for St Louis to try and keep that
11 gamer alive
[Music]
County Stadium Milwaukee the scene for
game three of the 1982 World Series in
the fifth inning of this scoreless time
hit high and deep to right field and
it's gone home run Willie McGee and the
Cardinals jump in front three to nothing
[Applause]
that's two for McGee another Homer
the side note had this he didn't know
what to do we go to the bottom of the
seventh inning 5-1 St Louis
and they are wild in Milwaukee
[Applause]
I'm five final score and all even at two
games a piece
here to game five
Molitor gets one out there Double Play
The Right Center Charlie Moore what an
outstanding play
well hit right field hold up
left field this could be it the
Milwaukee Brewers taking one game later
as we'll go back to St Louis
it's the MLB game of the week Live on
YouTube presented by Jim Beam good one
today Scott Braun Tom verducci Brett
Dolan in Milwaukee for the Cardinals and
the Brewers and the Roberto Clemente
award recognizes one player who best
represents the game through positive
contributions on and off the field learn
more about the nominees and vote at
mlb.com clemente21
look the lineup card top of the order
it's Edmund with Goldsmith on Deck and
the bases are full of cardinals here in
the seventh
Brewers five St Louis one Brad Boxberger
in the game
and he's had a nice season for Milwaukee
big strikeout numbers just do want to
point out One More Time Jake cousins out
of this game walked a couple in a row we
had the whole glove switch
and uh social media is buzzing about it
maybe threw him off his game a little
bit uh I wouldn't go that far but he
didn't have command and box Burger to me
he's in there because you saw last time
Hauser got Edmond out on four scene
fastballs up
that's box Burger out also has the
slider and change up but I would expect
elevated four seamers right here he's
not a ground ball pitcher
change up right there to start he's
thinking about a double play
he's throwing one double play ball this
year
only to Major Leagues you have an 11
chance of getting a double play when
it's in order
two percent for box Burger this year
Fly ball pitcher on the mound
got two strikes on Edmund I can't talk
you into these conspiracy theories on
the baseball field I'm not big on those
I don't I I didn't see
I didn't see cousins protest at all I
didn't see any body language that told
me he was out of sorts
punched out his first batter you're
right so
I poke I try
oh two hold for Edmund
contact right side there's one at second
back to First and he's safe and a run is
in it's 5-2 Sosa will step on home plate
one more time to make sure he's got it
and the inning stays alive
and RBI ground out for Edmund his team
now Trails by three and Edmund did make
the adjustment you saw him flatten out
the stroke right here was the fourth
seam fastball he runs so well it's
really hard to turn two on this ball
unless it's directly out of middle
infielder
has made it close
and you're right I saw
salsa I don't know whether you missed
home plate the first time but just to
make sure you had to walk back and touch
it because he was watching like the rest
of us to play at first base
it's the Justin Case tap
yeah I kind of like when you
have the remote control in your car door
you leave your car you park it you lock
it and like five seconds later did I
lock it you hit it again
just in case I'm big on that
sun is shining bright
through the window panels here at
American Family fields
I don't know if that's going to Face
Paul Goldschmidt
Goldie and aronado have video game
numbers in this ballpark
well right now the
the lighting for the hitter should be
okay balls in the sunlight the entire
time
you get the Shadows where it's going
dark to light or vice versa that creates
difficulty
now the sun just apparently went behind
a cloud
it's unheard us
either that or the roof opens and closes
faster than I thought
that'd be really quickly
[Music]
two on for Goldie with two outs
popped back
he sent one very far the other direction
last night cast powered by Google Cloud
433 feet it's the seventh longest home
run for him this season look at the
distance on you don't see baseballs go
that far very often in this ballpark
and Goldie
looking for a sponsorship yeah he's
sitting the ball hard this year in fact
his exit below is the highest it's been
this year since 2015.
way up from last year the seventh
biggest jump
more than three miles per hour this year
and jumped in exit Velo
it was Miller time last night for Goldie
he loves this ballpark too
there you go there's the numbers to
prove it
[Applause]
two cardinals in the top four for all
time
Ops right here in Milwaukee
let's see if box Burger sticks with that
slider I think he would
only much better fastball and off speed
hitter
than he is on the breaking ball
[Applause]
took to the changeup
instead of try it first and a run comes
in
Bader scores it's 5-3
admin hops to Second and this team known
for its base running also creates a run
just from that reputation yeah that's a
good call Scott because they do and I
mentioned Edmund especially really good
base runner
but if you're box Burger you're two outs
two strike you're controlling the count
why are you even throwing the first base
that's just not called for but
if you worry about the Cardinals running
game you make a throw you should make
that kicked off Edmund it was well off
the mark
one in now and one on
two and two is the count to Goldschmidt
two runs coming in
for the Cardinals seven
[Music]
didn't execute the slider there I'd be
real careful on fastball here
Goldschmidt break two strike fastball
hitter the other way
he's going to left Center Paul
Goldschmidt walloped that one and we are
tied
number 28 on the season they have come
storming back this team is dangerous
Paul goldschman Powers up for two the
Cardinals even the score at five
yeah I just wasn't in love with the
sequence there going back to the throw
to first base
goldschman is a 219 hitter against
breaking balls much more power and
dangerous against fastballs
the slider but you stay with that pitch
still in 2-2
and fastball just got too much of the
plate
there are certain hitters Scott that
never come off the fastball Goldsmith's
one of them
this team is feeling it right now
unfazed five unanswered runs
Goldie's done that 16 times in this
ballpark
we haven't seen many of those swings
from Tyler O'Neill I was thinking the
same thing Scott maybe the the lighting
is a little bit effective he just didn't
track that slider right there
he's definitely come back with it again
that Sunshine is back yeah you gotta
better pass it that one though
the previous one it just looked like he
didn't track at all
O'Neill over three today a couple
strikeouts
now an even count
yeah he's thinking you know one more
batter probably right here
battle in the seventh Boxberger fans
O'Neill but Paul Goldsmith to the rescue
[Applause]
a four run seven for St Louis
this was five nothing Milwaukee at one
point Tyrone Taylor with two home runs
well Goldie's got one a two-run shot and
a 5-5 contest on YouTube in Milwaukee
between two of the best in baseball
Bush Stadium in St Louis game six the
Milwaukee Brewers are just one game away
from the championship but key is on at
first Tommy heard is about it
here is Daryl Porter one ball one strike
and a high drive deeply
right home run and the Cardinals
celebrate a four-nothing lead
St Louis Cardinals are alive and well
the World Series is tied at three games
a piece they are ready here in St Louis
for game seven now it culminates into
one game for baseball's Championship
we're in the bottom of the sixth inning
of the final game of this 82 World
Series
[Applause]
the game is tied
lined into right field it's four to
three St Louis the whole city of St
Louis collectively holding his threat
three and two to count to Gorman Thomas
and that's the winner
that's the winner a World Series winner
for the Cardinals
[Applause]
do you work
[Applause]
hey check out the Brewers YouTube page
it's the best place to go behind the
scenes with the Milwaukee Brewers
subscribe so you never miss a video
and Google cloud is helping to power
statcast with massive amounts of data
points to reveal new insights taking you
deeper into the game than ever before
Google cloud is the official Cloud
technology of Major League Baseball
tied at five
finishing up a four-game set between the
Brewers and Cardinals these two teams
matching up 10 times this month they'll
have three more in St Louis to finish up
the season series
and TJ McFarland is in the game for St
Louis one of their big money pickups and
I mean that in terms of production as
you can see the numbers have been
magnificent for him this year and he is
a guy that relies on his defense just 16
strikeouts in 32 Innings well guess what
the Cardinals have the best defense in
baseball so that works yep keeps the
ball on the ground with the Sinker so
only six walks as well and a nice little
pocket for him right here
along the Lefty leading off Yelich
left-handed through up third
Bolton is one for three
and that's tailor-made for Edmond
on to adamis now
Tyrone Taylor has had a huge game
he helped this team get off to a 5-0
start but the rest of the offense has
been ice cold
they've dropped the first three games
against St Louis and if not for Tyrone
Taylor that would be the story
yeah I mean listen you have to applaud
their approach tonight I think the bats
have been better
had longer at bats
a couple of walks preceded the Grand
Slam
still not a ton of hard contact though
no
and you know I just know if I'm a
midfielder I'd love to play for the
Cardinals they don't shift a lot
the pitchers don't strike out a lot of
batters
balls in play
we're seeing that today
you are on your toes if you're a
Cardinal's infielder
see where William Thomas hits the ball
and if you are a Cardinals infield or
just defender in general you're likely
standing next to a gold Glover
or perhaps a future goldcliver
they are loaded in that category
oh just to drive home the point I like
to look at batting average on balls and
play especially this late in the season
Cardinals number two in baseball lowest
batting average on balls in play the
Dodgers are number one
is up the middle base hit
he likes the 1-2 pitch and he's aboard
that's why it's important to have good
balance in your lineup talk about a
pocket from McFarland
first right-handed hitter and the only
one of the first three
had a good swing at that sinker
[Music]
down to Lefty on Lefty yeah one 12.5 off
the bat for a Thomas
I think he heard that loud contact line
I hear out there had founding ever done
balls in play yeah and you're not going
to catch a lot of those 112.
Cardinals are best and outs above
average defensive run save all those
metrics they're number one as a team
nice pitch from McFarland yeah a
surprise Christian
first pitch Sinker in for a strike and
he's thinking okay I see the breaking
ball left on left
good way to jump ahead on the count
extra pause there tonight
there are very few on the planet that
love baseball like Yadi Molina so
he frames up a pitch like that
is
[Music]
feeling
grabs a little inner range
[Applause]
I think with from Yelich
I would expect another breaking ball
here
Cardinals like the Brewers don't shift a
lot they're 25th and the percentage of
shifts they use but they're shifted on
Christian Yelich
he's rolled over many baseballs exactly
that's how they're playing it and again
breaking balls we've talked about that
no home runs on breaking balls he
struggled against them this year
and that's part of it Scott is those
rollovers we're talking about as being
out front
on the breaking balls
that means ground ball right side
pulling it
that's how the Cardinals set him up
[Applause]
Christian doesn't sugarcoat things he
knows it hasn't been his best year I
remember last year at the end of the
season he said
quote all around terrible when he was
summing up what he did at the plate and
it just not
says not come around for him yet
[Music]
[Applause]
difficult past two seasons for him now
last year was a difficult season for a
lot of hitters JD Martinez Jose Altuve
really good hitters
yeah let's down on strikes because of
the short nature the weird nature of the
spring trainings but this year full
season He's just never gotten on track
and look at where his team is without
him being mvp-ish
yeah Sinker is just never on the plate
gets the chase swing with two strikes
not a good pass at the baseball
almost an emergency swing to protect on
a pitch that's really not that close
three for his last 37.
we'll see what Escobar can do
hit list today he walked in the first
and scored
what a turnaround in this one after a
grand slam from Tyrone Taylor in the
first inning off Adam Wainwright
small sample but good results for
Escobar against McFarland three for five
in a homer
foreign
defending the runner on first base so
the Cardinals Outfield especially deep
right now Bader and center field
plays one of the most shallow Center
fuels normally
you can see the positioning right there
they'll give up a single defending the
runner on first
Escobar goes to Bader
fancy footwork moving over
like an agility drill Harrison Vader
sure he can catch a football too
by five through seven
Fred bird doing a little fishing today
in Big Mac land has he forgotten all of
his animal instincts well that's not how
he's supposed to catch it that's a good
point did I tell you about the gift that
frederberg gave me a couple of years
back no I you didn't tell me showed me
well this reminded me sold me a nice
sweater is that right that's beautiful
got a little fretboards on you know like
the Christmas ones that have reindeer
all over it's like that but with Fred
birds what will fredbear do today while
he is vacuuming the cardboard cutouts
he figured I guess I got to get my
chores done
last night it was the ironing board and
tonight Fred bird is
bird watching he's a birder
he's got something new for us every game
and tonight apparently he is back to
school and it looks like he is virtually
learning and yes that is Fred bird and
yes I do believe that is
Tiger King Tiger King
very appropriate exotic that may be his
best one yet I think so
hahaha
[Music]
let's go back to the seventh inning how
close did Milwaukee come to getting off
the field with a three-run lead six outs
to go well this close they thought they
might get Tommy in on a double play but
no
just barely beat it out and that's
setting up for Paul Goldsmith who
absolutely hammered this fastball from
Brad Boxberger
to tie the game
[Applause]
so close
to getting out of that jam but instead
here we sit tied in the eighth inning
talked about the over under on Nolan
arenado's RBIs I said I didn't like his
chances if he let off every time up
that's what he's doing he's done that
he's leading off to the eighth inning so
you'll need a homer
so far over three no ribbies
that MGM with the odds there on him
contributing an RBI that's the X Factor
though you'd need some guys on or a solo
shot Here Comes Aaron Ashby and the
Brewers have been a pitching Factory and
here's the latest to come out of it
Big Time stuff the numbers are fine 277
and his first adding was messy after
that he's been Elite on the mound so
a 277 earned run average he popped up
on the 17th in Milwaukee his last
appearance three scoreless five
strikeouts no walks he is picking up
steam and looking like he is going to be
another talented arm out of the
Milwaukee Bullpen come playoff time
yeah and obviously Craig Council trusts
him as platoon neutral left or right
because of that pitch right there the
slider
see a lot of Sliders that's his Elite
pitch and
it's also a tough solve because he hides
the ball so well
that's his primary pitch he uses the
slider a bit more than the Sinker on the
season yeah it's his go-to pitch
as a hitter you want to try to pick up
the baseball as soon as possible
certainly before release point
and Ashby keeps his arm behind him as he
swings it back behind his body so you
don't see it stays closed a long time
throws you that glove at you a la Andy
Pettit and then all of a sudden the
baseball appears
the longer a hitter can see a baseball
including before the release the better
off he is
Aaron is 23 a fourth round pick by
Milwaukee in 2018 out of crowder Junior
College Missouri the same alma mater
as Uncle Andy who pitched in the big
leagues for parts of 14 seasons
Ball Four are Renato lead off man aboard
Cardinals have a base runner to start
the eighth
saw the Milwaukee bench kind of alerting
Reyes to Third Base the possibility of a
button right here
I would let Carlson hit but the way the
Cardinals play you definitely have to at
least defend against the possibility
Bill and seeing the ball well today too
single triple and a fly out
the rookie with 15 home runs switch
hitter and better from this side of the
plate as well
348 against leftists
and there he goes
right side and Off to the Races aronado
is head bursts in there
nice Chuck from Taylor in right field he
fell on the throw yeah I'm going to
disagree with you on that because again
Cardinals are a great base running team
and you're looking at Carlson at second
base because of that throw that's right
didn't think he had a shot at aronado
and throw is too high out of the hands
so Carlson reads the throw out of the
hand as high
and look at him that's an easy read for
him
Ball's not cuttable
Cardinals are in business second and
third nobody out
special teams for the Cardinals come
through again base running
Milwaukee will have to bring the infield
in
and we've seen it already today he's got
Yadi Molina scoring position loves to
attack the first pitch
aronado walked heads to third on the
Carlson base hit
he advances to second on the throw
two in scoring position Yadi doesn't go
out to the first pitch but it skips away
and the Cardinals grabbed the lead
aronado come on down it's 6'5
[Applause]
be interesting how they score it
talk about hitters tracking a baseball
I'm not sure the peanut tracked this one
well fastball at 99.
like it handcuffed him a little bit
yeah it just didn't really react to it
in time
[Applause]
they read lips there one pitch at a time
just trying to slow him down here
games speeding up on Ashby
I thought that pitch was really his
fault
but it hasn't been able to land that
slider so far
fastball
[Applause]
that 2-0 to Molina we have not seen Evan
Williams
gosh haters the ninth inning man for
Milwaukee
in the center Kane giving it a look
at the wall he's got it just enough
space but it's good for a sack fly off
the bat of Yadi Molina to make it 7-5 St
Louis Carlson comes in and make it seven
unanswered runs from the hottest team in
baseball looking for a 12th consecutive
win and now a two run cushion
that they play Such Great fundamental
baseball and Yadi Molina is part of that
great situational hitter
the situation you want to use the big
part of the field and get the ball in
the air that's a completely different
swing than we saw earlier with a man on
second base this is the swing designed
to hit the big part of the field in the
air
as a hitter you want to keep the ball
away from the corners stay away from the
rollover
the out delivers the Run he almost got a
little more than the the out as well
then did a long way died down a bit
Kane tracked it well against the wall
Sosa going to right
good mustard on that one if it stays
Fair it's foul
two runs knocked in by Yadi Molina today
[Applause]
he knows he had a chance he thought
maybe he had it
yeah almost
foreign
[Music]
let's see where that baseball ended up
well that's exactly what they're doing
in New York right now
[Music]
ball did bounce in the stands right so
they could
if you think it's fair it looks foul to
me
could put them on second base if they
determined that the ball actually landed
in Fair territory it looked foul or at
minimum I don't have to turn it over
it is a blind Corner in the stadium so
we get the same views that New York City
does
I don't think it's going to be
enough evidence
yeah it's a foul ball
we needed the camera from the sky on
that one right
yeah
roof cam yeah
[Music]
so I guess you're wondering about
Williams possibility maybe using him in
the eighth yeah that's where I was
starting yeah
well you might have to do that in the
next half so sick is retired
but we got time two outs yeah
it's certainly an option for sure
tight game you're in this losing streak
you're at home
Ashby does have reverse splits that
slider has played really well against
right-handed hitters so I get that but
you did turn Carlson over to his better
side
aronado right-handed leading off
I mean Williams you don't care right
your left is one of the best Believers
in the game get him in
it spoke to the confidence in Ashby of
getting right-handed hitters out
didn't work
these are Big moments for some unproven
relievers out of the pen
you know I it's funny because I sort of
anticipated this because I asked Craig
Council if he had relief pitchers today
he really wanted to get the game because
a lot of times when you're in a losing
streak and you haven't used
I call them your winning pieces pictures
you'd like to use to protect leads
sometimes you just want to get them out
there get them on the mound
actually the one guy he mentioned was
Ashby
I thought maybe you wanted to get
Williams or hater out there
but he said you'll probably see Ashby
today
he got up yesterday
didn't get into the game
talking about Ashby
it's a very short day for Brett Anderson
and his return from the injured list
yesterday removed in the second
Cardinals pounced and won it 10-2
yesterday
underwater swing from Bader hitting over
two more for the Cardinals seven runs in
a row against Milwaukee
they lead by two mid eight we'll see if
the Brewers bats have more in them
specifically you Tyrone we're looking at
you
[Music]
on July 7 2008 the Milwaukee Brewers
made one of the biggest trades in
franchise history when they acquired
reigning Cy Young winner CeCe Sabathia
from Cleveland they made the move with
one goal in mind make the postseason for
the first time since 1982. we felt
before we got CeCe that we were a pretty
good club but what cc did was just give
us incredible depth and you know the ace
departs
[Applause]
we've made it loud and clear hey we're
going to do everything that we can do to
uh bring our fans postseason baseball
way
waste your piece Sabathia went 11-2 with
Milwaukee pitching on three days rest in
three consecutive starts down the
stretch the Brewers win again and CeCe
Sabathia his third straight complete
game and on that final day of the 2008
season CeCe delivered his most clutch
performance of the Year leading the
Brewers to their first postseason in
nearly two and a half decades yeah
a complete game
[Applause]
what a pickup
[Applause]
[Applause]
back in Wisconsin for the Brewers and
Cardinals Cardinals going for the super
sweep they've taken the first three in
this series the Brewers are going for
their first world series title in
franchise history they made it in 1982
to the fall classic but since the
franchise was born in 1969 they haven't
picked up a crown
same with the Rangers Padres Mariners
Rockies and rays and there's been a lot
of success from Milwaukee lately but
wait I spy Devin Williams Behind Craig
Council who we were just talking about
pondering why maybe he wouldn't be in
the game in the eighth inning he's in
the Dugout what does that mean not
available
from Luis Garcia the 34 year old who's
had massive control issues in his career
except for this year yeah
and you're on your toes because he's got
that power Sinker not just the velocity
but good arm side run right on right be
careful
Maria's Taylor Kane do up in the eighth
that's down there
one and one now the Brewers have done
the comeback effort quite often this
year 38 comeback wins second most in the
National League
the Cardinal Bullpen is really
solidified
with some sneaky pickups like Luis
Garcia who has found it
at 34 years old
DJ McFarland we saw in the previous
inning he's been a huge pickup for them
there were strike throwing issues for
the staff as a whole if you looked at
the numbers but that was fixed we spoke
this morning to Mike Schult about it
because it wasn't a philosophical change
it was a transactional change they
picked up pitchers that know how to find
the zone
Maria's broke his Bat a little floater
no problem for O'Neill
[Applause]
oh those bad companies today they're
watching this pumping
well I'm just thinking about the top of
this ending Scott it reminds me baseball
really is a game that is played in 90
foot increments
can't give 90 feet away for free and
that's what the Brewers did starting
with a lead off walk that's a free base
Carlson goes Carlson goes to second on a
single
on a high throw that's not cuttable
run scores in the past ball he moves to
third on the pass balls another free
base which winds up costing that extra
run on the sac fly by Molina it's just
too many free bases in any kind of a
game but especially a tie game
gates in it we're seeing those small
things that are overlooked in highlights
pop up a lot lately for the Cardinals
[Applause]
Taylor's the hot hand
two home runs today Grand Slam in the
first
[Applause]
one more in on his Homer in the fourth
that's it for Milwaukee today
Garcia got him
yachty double clutched he knew it was a
strike but didn't get the call right
away
delayed call from Carlos Torres and
maybe
here I'll throw another conspiracy
theory at you yeah he's been
disappointed sometimes in the zone today
he's like what what was it
Carlos says hey Carlos Torres behind
home plate yeah you got it this time
strike three but I'll make you wait for
it
what a story Luis Garcia has been picked
up by the Cardinals on July 9th he was
cut by the Yankees he was the Triple A
Closer and that looks like good stuff
from your AAA closer 100 with a lot of
movement
well you hit on the big Key Scott the
ability to throw strikes you can't put
someone out there who's
throwing a lot of walks
control issues in the eighth inning
trying to hold a two-run lead but Mike
Shield has trust in Garcia
loads of walks in his lifetime
but it has all come together
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
Kane held back a ball in two strikes
two down in the eighth
we're getting to the point for St Louis
where
you can start previewing playoff
matchups
second wild card
looks like it will be theirs
will it be against the Giants or the
Dodgers we'll see
if it's La might be a
classic showdown between Max Scherzer
and Adam Wainwright
[Music]
Kane to left and a foul ball
and a nice grab
but
here's the X Factor
tomorrow making one of the starts there
you go
a little air too nice
so tomorrow Jack Flaherty is making one
of the starts in a double header day for
the Cardinals against the Cubs Flaherty
is not going to go along might be only
an inning or two but Jack's back
came past short
two outs one on for the Brewers after
the Kane single let's kick it to Brad
for a little more on what could be a
huge deal for the Cardinals tomorrow
well it certainly is getting Flaherty
back will be a nice boost and keep in
mind with four games in three days they
could use the odds but Flaherty was
having a great season nine and two a 3-0
era like shook didn't commit to how many
pitches he would throw maybe more of an
opener situation remember though he also
has Dakota Hudson at his Avail was
supposed to pitch yesterday on a rehab
with Memphis they didn't go through with
that that means he might end up having
that rehab or if they really need him
they could bring him up basically a year
removed from Tommy John
and those are two talented arms
two of the better arms on the roster
when they're feeling good
Annie Pina doubled last time up
oh I strike oh Scott you said Jack's
back but we don't know in what form yet
but if he's close to his usual form I
think he does become an option even
without length in one run game you see
this depth of the St Louis bullpen
I think he could put himself in play at
least as an option
Pina to aronado and he's gonna throw him
out
yeah maybe Flaherty starts the wild card
game give you a few Innings Cardinals
have been asking a lot but it's possible
Cardinals have been able to score runs
early in games they play fundamental
baseball bullpen's been great just
saying big comeback day for them so far
on to the ninth
[Music]
come on back
baby cut
strike one on that's right one
[Music]
good ball
oh wow yeah a lot of wind huh
cut back cut back
that wasn't good
ah [ __ ]
[Music]
sit ball
pretty good pretty good
[Music]
yes sir man Mike what a pleasure man
that was fun we got a place when you get
back to St Louis you got to play love it
man thanks for having me out all right
thanks for being on this is all good
you're watching the MLB game of the week
Live on YouTube presented by Jim Beam
last day on the YouTube slate what a
year it's been what a game today
number five who had number five probably
Corbin Burns he knows everything
he predicted the Grand Slam in the first
inning but
after jumping out to a five-nothing lead
the Cardinals Scurry back they rushed
the Brewers it's 7-5 and we're in the
ninth and St Louis is trying to put
together a 12th consecutive win and a
chance to add on some runs here against
Aaron Ashby who's back on the mound
by the way thanks to Corbin Burns for
wearing the bike I can't get enough of
that stuff I love hearing the players
and uh all the guys who wear the mic and
they've done it all year for us thanks
so much I'm sure the fans would say the
same thing oh it's gold and you can hear
much more of it on play lab The Hit
YouTube show
Jose Rondon pinchitter valves one
who's got a Thomas going hard slides but
he's not there he caught it off I got it
that I ran all this way I might as well
catch the darn thing
tried to sell it
he's great he's entertaining he is just
a pleasure to be around
high energy
that's why when adamus has missed some
time lately
he is a handful in The Dugout watching
games
non-stop chatter
Rick Council said at one point he was
annoying just in the way that he wanted
to get back on the field saying he was
feeling good it's like a kid on a rainy
day can't go outside and play driving
Mom and Dad crazy
he came back from the aisle Monday and
he said he couldn't sleep on Sunday that
was the excitement it's like opening day
first day of the post-season excitement
[Music]
rondone pinchitting we saw Garcia handle
the eighth
should be Gallegos in the ninth for the
Cardinals
pop up
another chance Eduardo Escobar over the
shoulder no in right field it's Tyrone
Taylor to the rescue
wow remember earlier we had Corbin burns
on a pop-up in that direction say we got
a guy there well maybe not
you don't figure the right Fielder's
gonna get there
and there he is
Taylor comes out of nowhere with a
spectacular diving catch
[Music]
you see that last look that he had just
to see where that wall was and that's
the way you do it the wind was Sly its
way of putting on the brakes so you
don't run into the wall
I don't want to say he made that look
easy but that is a very difficult play
just pulled off
that's a special role player for the
Brew Crew
Escobar kind of stopped and I was
looking during the race yeah that's not
me I was looking to see if Taylor his
mouth moved to see if he was calling for
it I didn't see anything basketball was
like a little help this time please
these two teams are a pleasure to watch
on defense
oh yeah
they get after it
the range that they show too you know we
talked about how they're among the teams
that shift the least
and I truly believe Scott if going
forward talking about next year baseball
is able to put a governor on shifts
see Edmond gets a look after found that
ball off the foot
actually highlights the athleticism and
range of the players more if we put
Governors on his shift we're talking
about limiting it to say two infielders
on each side of the base
[Music]
yeah that didn't get the pad that got
the foot
[Music]
extra minute to walk it off
and then climb back in but
you're right there would be more ground
to cover
right
if the shifts are limited
I've talked to Francisco on the door
about that and he's in favor of that
let's see the pulse Break Free for that
very reason let us show off our athletic
ability
is
Ashby gets through Edmond it's Paul
goldschmidt's turn statcast powered by a
Google Cloud he did it again
and he did
106.6 exit below
talked about how Boxberger didn't
execute the slider on the pitch before
and went right back to really build its
strength on that fastball he didn't miss
it
he's a strong candidate for
that trophy two player of the game yes
game deciding Homer at the moment for
Goldie
he scored four runs yesterday
he's been on a roll since late June it
was a slow start with some
unlucky contact I guess you could call
it he was squaring up the baseball if
you watched him on a daily basis at the
beginning of the season
well Noah just seems at the end of the
year those numbers always look very
similar don't they
him and aronado
3-1 is set to left Center all the
outfielders are just gonna watch it go
Paul Goldsmith has a two home run day
it's 8-5
he's up to 29 on the year and the
Cardinals are clicking on all cylinders
right now they're a force
Scott when he hit that ball I watched
Kane and Yelich neither one flinched
that was so loud the sound of contact
oh my goodness
it was like tympani in the orchestra
boom
a little Wagner
from Goldsmith watch the outfielders
the yikes watch out in a beer garden
thank you
my goodness that ball hammered
the sound told the story
too much lift on this one from O'Neill
and there's Kane to end the top of the
ninth but another run for St Louis
well Paul Goldschmidt boosted this team
in front with his two run shot in the
seven
Encore yes please
eight five Cardinals going for the super
sweep and a 12th consecutive win if they
can pick up three more outs the
conclusion coming up
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
just
this one will go down in history has an
all-time
unbelievable a leadoff home run by David
freeze be tied it with a two-run triple
in the bottom of the night he wins it
here in the 11th
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
the Cardinals trying to extend their
winning streak to 12 straight games when
the Cardinals make the postseason this
year guys Mike shield and his team will
have been in the postseason 15 times
since 2000. the Yankees have been there
17 times then the Cardinals will be 15
Dodgers 13 Braves 12. maybe when they
were 69 and 68 this month it didn't look
like a possibility they've lost just
once since
Brett it's an incredible run by the
Cardinals and it continues there are so
many reasons to point to here's one
Giovanni Gallegos has taken over as the
closer since the end of August and he
has shined in this spot
yeah I like what Mike Shield did the
other night before he put He Walked
Yelich intentionally to load the bases
and just had that much confidence in
Gallegos not just to close the game but
to throw strikes
he did and he did he fanned Pablo Reyes
to end that one that was one of the
close ones
a 2-1 win on Tuesday they took it 5-2
Monday yesterday 10-2
and right now 7-5 with pinch hitter
Daniel vogelbak stepping in
you can point back to vogelbach's Grand
Slam walk across the down three maybe I
mean Reyes was in there now it's been
Gallegos in the ninth well it's just one
of the turnarounds you can look at
because the Cardinals have played
Sensational baseball since then
many teams would have been heartbroken
after that point and looking up in the
standings teams to push past it just
looked incredibly Bleak for St Louis
they did pick up big names at the trade
deadline although veterans that filled
in Innings like John Lester and Jay Happ
yeah but Scott I do see that veteran
presence there playing a role in that
turnaround
even if it's not direct indirect guys
that have been there done that the less
there's the haps the Molina is the
wainwrights aaronato's Goldschmidt so
much experience here
[Applause]
knowing there was still time and they've
built this the cliche but one win one
game at a time and this may be their
best yet a streak
down five runs
eight unanswered so far
[Applause]
I was looking at this today Scott
if this is their 12th straight win 12
wins in a row not just
that alone is great right in September
it's only been done eight times in
baseball history
[Applause]
last time was in 1999.
by the Astros
s that's something special they're doing
right here
got one caveat for you though Scott
uh-oh
there's a strike to Vogel back two and
two and I know we think of the 07
Rockies as the perfect example of how to
end a season and ride that momentum into
the postseason right
really doesn't matter postseason is
momentum all its own it doesn't matter
if you're playing well or poorly I think
the most important thing going to the
postseason is where you are health-wise
especially your pitchers
[Music]
up in the zone Gallegos with a K one
down in the ninth so would you rather be
playing really good baseball in
September going into the postseason of
course but history tells us there's not
a statistical advantage of probability
advantage
you know if you're the Cardinals you can
run the table here but it still comes
down to maybe one game winner go home
and anything can happen in that short
sample
and a chance to be I don't want to say
the ultimate Underdog but when you look
out west at what the Giants and Dodgers
have put together this year if the
Cardinals are able to pull off a win in
that wild card game it would be epic and
historic because the second best record
in baseball might belong to a team that
has one game with its season on the line
to start the postseason
I mean that's crazy for some I do agree
that the pressure is on that other team
from the West in the wild card game and
that could
be to the Cardinals advantage to use
that in their favor
and boy then you really have momentum I
know we're getting ahead of ourselves
but you think about
what the Nationals did to the Brewers in
the wild card game
the Royals to the A's in 2015 in the
wild card game whose season starts like
that
feel like like you're invincible
and they are going to be able to set
themselves up for that wild card game
that's important they're not fighting to
the Finish Line at this point St Louis
is close to wrapping up the second Wild
Card seat with this run that they're on
and that will let them
set up whoever they want for that game
Adam Wainwright based on his schedule
could have gone on the last day of the
Season you're not going to need him most
likely so you can save him for the wild
card game we saw a shot of Jack Flaherty
couple minutes ago he might pop up in
that game
foreign
who stands out
the U2 player of the game decided by you
Paul Goldschmidt Dylan Carlson Yadi
Molina take your pick
vote right now it's on your screen press
click do it
Tom verbally from you
oh my ears still hurt that last home run
that gold Schmidt hit so
that's where I would go
I mean listen I I love the finer points
of the game the base running we've
talked about the things that the St
Louis Cardinals do well their defense
but man
nothing like that home run
turn things around eighth inning and
then add on to the ninth
the campaign is on Tom Goldie
the seventh inning is the first of the
home runs
he's six for nine in his last two days
three homers five RBIs have a series
you called it you said he'd love hitting
in his Park he really does
he saw this park a little as a
diamondback now a lot as a cardinal to
his favor
and that's the thing you moved to the NL
Central and specifically to St Louis
that's definitely a pitcher's ballpark
less hit or friendly than Arizona but
some of the opponents in the division
have friendly ballparks for hitters
no
long stays alive
you know I was a little surprised to
actually checking the park factors today
for American Family field it's actually
middle of the pack in terms of offense
it does seem like it's more of a hitters
park than a pitcher's Park
and the statcast pack Park factors do
work on three-year controlling averages
like it does have a reputation it's a
good hitter Spark
I'm sure that's what Paul Goldschmidt
would tell us yes
went out in the ninth 2-2 from Gallegos
on one hop for Edmund
two gone and part of the reason why I
think the Cardinals could be so
dangerous in that one gamer is
they don't hurt themselves with mistakes
and we've been gushing about their
defense and Milwaukee really can pick it
on D2 the base running for St Louis
seeing this bullpen
become a problem for opposing teams in
the way that it's set up now
just saying
yeah I mean how about the job by the St
Louis Bullpen today
lights out
amazing
[Music]
Milwaukee's bull tank got in trouble
with some blocks
St Louis has avoided
first pitch strike to Adamas
this would be the largest lead blown by
Milwaukee this year previously
four runs on August 3rd against
Pittsburgh in a loss
this would be the largest comeback of
the year for the Cardinals
I've always said Scott when it comes to
pitching late in the game especially
closers but let's go even eighth inning
it's so key to avoid walks and home runs
I mean that sounds obvious you don't
want them anytime but it's hard to
string hits together against Power arms
the bullpen so don't give up three bases
and keep the ball in the ballpark and
that's really what harmed the Milwaukee
Bullpen today
two walks in front of the Home Run and a
walk to start the rally in the eighth
inning
they're one strike away I think back to
the fifth and we'll get into this more
post game show 30 minutes devoted to
these two teams right here same spot but
Kim came in he walked the pitcher Hauser
to start the frame but
he was able to escape
that base is loaded one out yeah out of
it
hey
last time the Cardinals won 12 in a row
1982.
40 years ago
[Applause]
that was a World Series pretty good year
for St Louis yeah you know who they beat
in the World Series I do this Milwaukee
team
young outfielders O'Neil Bader Carlson
[Applause]
it wasn't the best day for Adam
Wainwright it was a tight Zone he didn't
have command of his curveball early on
and they replaced him with a pinch
hitter after four innings
and two bad pitches to Taylor he didn't
let him get away with either one
a Grand Slam in the solo shot
boy his teammates pick him up today
the offense wasn't there early in the
year for the Cardinals
it's happening right now
[Applause]
all right
Scott I'm a big fan of chaos I like
pennant races that are complicated many
teams go down the last day the Cardinals
are taking chaos
that was the national league Wild Card
race
is too good right now
yeah it's not close anymore not with
only a week and a half to go in the
season
not as well as they're playing as
soundly as they're playing
3-2 last call for Milwaukee Game Over
The Comeback is complete and official
and the win streak continues for the
Cardinals
[Applause]
an 83rd win on the year St Louis has
racked up 12 in a row
from five nothing to 8-5 and a final
the Cardinals sweep the Brewers in four
games in Milwaukee these two teams will
match up for three more in St Louis to
end the season series what a comeback
effort which included two home runs from
Paul Goldschmidt
so much more to go for us here
we have two teams with story lines all
over the place let's break it down post
game show now
foreign
show is presented by Jim Bemo where do
we start the 12 consecutive wins the 16
and 6th September they've won 14 of 15.
they were down five nothing they come
back and take it 8-5 they take the
series against the first place Brewers
Milwaukee had a chance yeah there was 2
000 strikeouts the milestone for Adam
Wainwright but Milwaukee had a chance
when we opened up this series
to wrap up the division and their Rivals
said no not on our watch not the way
we're playing baseball right now Mike
Schultz smiling again after another
Cardinals Victory make it 8-5 where do
you want to start Tom braducci I want to
start with the fact that score is five
to nothing down five nothing let's
remember it's a day game after a night
game it's the last game of a four-game
series on the road not saying the
Cardinals would have packed it in
but the intensity remained the
fundamental way they play baseball
remain good solid relief work out of the
relievers the way they ran the bases
they're at bats yes the two big home
runs by Goldschmidt got about gonna
hurry and a head in a hurry
but I just love the way this team
responded to being down five to nothing
to a really good Milwaukee team on the
road Day game after night game
everything in place to say that game was
over uh-uh Cardinals right now
are literally unbeatable and they are
relentless
12 wins in a row when it was five five
Paul Goldschmidt showed off his muscles
two home runs today
two runs in the seventh and then one
more in the ninth he is your YouTube
player of the game final trophy of the
year
and he's got Hardware here's another one
put it in the trophy case Paul
what a performance today three hits he
went three for five
two more home runs 29 this season when
you look at the back of the digital
baseball card it's consistent and colty
wins this one by a landslide yeah this
was easy yeah go Goldie go 90 of you say
reward this man and talk to him on the
post game show which we'll do right now
Paul Scott Braun and Tom verducci
congratulations on the W The Comeback
win the 12 in a row the YouTube trophy
you're a strong dude but there's some
weight on that right yeah this thing's
heavier than I thought heavier than it
looks for sure anytime you get a trophy
it's usually a good thing though bicep
curls hey for you two home runs today
take us through the at-bats in the
seventh and the ninth what did you see
um you know that about there in the
South was a big one you know we were
down on two and you know just trying to
get on base and you know pass the buck
to O'Neill behind me and was able to get
fastball kind of up and uh you know get
enough of it to get it out of here
yeah take me a little bit deeper into
that because I think he missed with the
slider Away Paul and to me it seems like
you never get off the fastball you're
always on time there tell me about your
approach specifically then and overall
yeah well I mean when you got two
strikes you can't be guessing up there
so uh you know just you know choked up
and and just tried to stay short to the
ball you know box Burger's got a good
fastball just you know try to get on top
of it a little bit and was able to do it
there but um you know just with two
strikes like I said just trying to put
the ball and play hopefully something
good happens and um was able to you know
hit a mistake right there Paul what's
been the most impressive part of this
win streak for the team
probably just everyone doing their job
you know we've had to call on a lot of
different guys um O'Neill's had some big
homers Nolan just all parts of the team
you saw you know even just some walks
you know even to get some guys on base
right there the other day
um you know some stolen bases were
really big we only won two to one so
we've just won a lot of different ways
um you know pitching our Bullpen our
starters they've all been doing a great
job and um you know just been on a good
little streak hey Paul we were talking
here about your numbers in this yard
they're really among the best ever since
it opened up is there something about
this place as a hitter a background
something that you really like that sets
up well for you
oh you know I don't know you know the
first couple games I was over eight and
I was like uh you know who knows what's
gonna happen but you know I was able to
have a good day yesterday and today and
um you know who knows I mean I don't
know I don't put too much stock in it
each day I just try to take it one day
at a time try to have good at bats and
uh just let the results be what they may
hey this team has looked different in
the month of September it's no secret
and there's also quite a few new players
in the mix especially on the pitching
side and John Lester's added to this
team and so is Jay Happ we talked about
some of the bullpen members which we saw
today Luis Garcia TJ McFarland now is
that a huge part of the difference for
St Louis because otherwise you know
there's been this Core Group here and we
just didn't see it in the first half of
the season this team looks like a
playoff baseball team in the second half
what's the biggest reasoning in your
mind yeah I mean you hit the nail on the
head I mean you know we have had a bunch
of our guys together and I think we're
playing you know better baseball but I
think having guys like John Lester and
Jay Happ come in has really uh
solidified that rotation uh you know
everyone's Got Confidence when they've
been on the mound and then you know the
guys in the bullpen Garcia McFarland I'm
sure I'm forgetting someone else but uh
you know those guys have filled in and
just done a great job and then the guys
that have been here all year have you
know continue to do their job and just
kind of uh you know play better this
last month or so hey a two-part question
here defensively is this the best
defense you've ever been a part of the
numbers say at the eye test says it from
what we've seen so far and then here go
go for that I'll get you one more for
the kids watching on YouTube yeah it's
up there I mean I don't really like to
make comparisons you know we had one
year in Arizona where I think we led the
league in defense two and the last
couple years we were pretty good here
too so you know whatever numbers say we
can trust them but uh it's definitely a
big part of our game some great plays
all the way around and something we lean
on Paul many youngsters learn the game
by watching their favorite players on
YouTube these days looking back at Clips
I would say to a young first baseman out
there hey watch Paul goldschman what he
does with his picks his range the whole
deal let's talk about the defense for a
moment if you could give a tip to the
little Leaguers watching out there what
would it be on how to improve your game
at first base which is a position that
sometimes is overlooked but is crucial
to the infield defense
yeah I mean I mean it's it sounds too
simple but just get out there and
practice so there's not like one drill
that'll teach you but I think a lot of
times defense gets overlooked even for
me you know coming up in the minor
league my first couple years I'm like oh
I play first base I gotta hit and then
really when I you know made it to focus
and said man if I get to the big they're
not gonna call me up if I don't play
good D and kind of start practicing in
the off season in spring training
um you know and obviously every day
throughout the year and that kind of you
know I saw myself improve a lot and same
thing now you know every day we're out
there working working on picks working
on ground balls throwing the bases so I
think the biggest thing is just you know
don't overlook it because it's a big
part of the game and you know offense is
going to go up and down you're gonna go
through your struggles but if you can
play good defensively you'll stay in the
lineup you'll help your team win in a
lot of different ways and um you know
makes a lot more fun reps kids it shows
Paul thank you so much congratulations
this is our last YouTube game of the
season so can you just hold it up for us
one more time there's a lot in there
yeah that's gonna have your name on it
we appreciate it thanks Paul thank you
all right
congratulations to the St Louis
Cardinals for the W12 in a row statcast
powered by Google Cloud hook us up with
the long balls
and the audio too right yeah the sound
was spectacular and also for the kitties
at home listen to what he just said on
that home run against box Burger two
strikes he choked up on the bat and
shortened up and hit the ball a mile and
a half
let that be a lesson too Paul Goldsmith
is a smart man
he's a cardinal he just fits in so well
to this organization he's having a nice
little 12 gamer right now 378 5 11
brought in he scored 19 times he scored
twice today four times yesterday scored
six times the past 48 hours and the Ops
is pretty nice too and now a trophy he
hopes for another trophy the Cardinals
are gonna be in that October dance
and they super sweep the Brewers we'll
get into the Milwaukee conversation too
that's where we are for more time here
on the post game show coming up
[Applause]
the Brewers have the lead
he's a very good baseball announcer and
if you listen to Bob for five or six
minutes you wanted to say something
that's going to make you laugh as
Driscoll makes the proper call defensive
indifference or as we call it and score
it who cares Bob has had this wonderful
ability to give you the game and then
bang you know that's where major league
three was filmed is that right yeah I
haven't seen it don't that thing was so
bad it was on airplanes the day we
finished it he's very funny on the air
but he is just an exceptionally good
broadcaster swinging a looping ladder
the right center
one run is in they're gonna try to score
Luke Roy here's the throw he's in there
you really feel the game through him and
while certainly he's a brewer
broadcaster so in that sense he's a
homer he's not a Mindless Homer he'll
give you a fair call of the game Morgan
will smash up the middle
above around third a throw in the
Brewers win
foreign
Taylor brand slammed for him in his
career exactly two months ago against
the White Sox
[Applause]
Tyrone Taylor muscles up it's his second
grand slam of the season and the Brewers
hanged four on Wayne Right in the first
[Applause]
what a moment for Tyrone Taylor
1999 career strikeouts many are on the
edge of their seat waiting for the big
number to emerge and that
welcome to the club 2
000 career strikeouts for Adam
Wainwright
and he has a seat next to Bob Gibson as
the only two pitchers in Cardinals
history to punch out 2K
and fittingly it was Uncle Charlie the
curveball her career strikeout number
2000 first K of the day for Wainwright
hits a major Milestone and he's the
ninth player to reach 2000 strikeouts
with only a single franchise and now the
matchup with Taylor Taylor gets another
good rip oh wow
what a day is there a Home Run Cycle
because he has a grand slam and a solo
shot in his first two AVS five-nothing
Milwaukee Tyrone Taylor with his second
career multi-homer game the Brewers love
him as a losing streak stopper
potentially if he can keep things
rolling four in a third three strikeouts
Carlson gets a hold of one into right
field and that is a fair ball and he's
heading for two and now heading for
three Dylan Carlson on the run and he's
in there with a one out triple and a
Beat underreported aspects of baseball
their defense and their base running oh
that's classic first [ __ ] he loves to
do that in an RBI spot and he comes
through the Cardinals are on the board
it's 5-1 the Cardinals load up the bases
back to the top of the order in Tommy
Edmond
[Applause]
[Music]
it's for rias the Cardinals strand the
base is loaded phase one for three today
O'Neill is coming up
that is making a nice stop with the
glove and the throw the short way is in
time to erase Goldsmith look at Maria's
now he has Aaron's velor this year but
it's it's on the arm
with the glove the glove's been great
Dylan Carlson's been the best bat today
for St Louis
Carlson spits it to Let's and Yelich
right in front of the track
we'll end this inning to Adrian Hauser
has himself another scoreless frame and
a 5-1 Edge faces full of cardinals with
just one out in the seven or two hole
for Edmund
contact right side there's one at second
back to first
two if you on for Goldie with two outs
instead of try it first and a run comes
in Vader scores it's 5-3 admin hops to
Second and this team known for its base
running also creates a run just from
that reputation one in now and one on
he's going to left Center all gold
Schmidt Wallops that one and we are tied
number 28 on the season they have come
storming back this team is dangerous
Paul goldschman Powers up for two the
Cardinals even the score at five
oh but wait there's more aranatos on
first in the eighth Dylan Carlson has
hit number three on the day quietly a
great performance from the rookie
and then Tommy didn't like this well I
liked it face running on his part throw
goes all the way to third so he takes
second base and that turned out to be a
big base he moved to Third on a wild
pitch right here as the Run scored
and then being on third base with less
than two outs well Yadi knows what to do
in that situation got him in with the
sacrifice fly almost got out of the arc
Here Comes Carlson
now it's suddenly 7-5 St Louis what a
flip of the script in the ninth gold
Schmidt's not done
he'll tell you when he's done
just some
Majestic blasts thunderous smacks from
Paul Goldschmidt in the past few days
bottom of the inning Gallegos their
ninth inning man these days
[Applause]
it's over and it's a 12th straight win
for St Louis that's the longest winning
streak for a team in the National League
since 2017 when the Arizona Diamondbacks
won 12 in a row and that was Paul
goldschbitzball Club
just saying who knows what this is like
he knows the field your gym beam game
summary Goldie three for five two homers
the YouTube player of the game trophy
Carlson with three hits Wayne Wright
with his 2 000th career strikeout him
and Bob Gibson the only two in Cardinals
franchise history hey let's not Overlook
Tyrone Taylor had a big day two home
runs solo shot ran slam but let's flip
it back to the Cardinal side another
conversation with a player post game
Brett take it away
Scott when you think about the position
players for the St Louis Cardinals it's
easy to focus on Goldschmidt Arenado or
Molina they have a nice young Trio as
well O'Neal Edmund and Carlson Carlson
had three base hits today caught up to
him just a few moments ago and I asked
him what it was like to be part of a
team that has won 12 straight games
oh it's awesome it's been real exciting
time and uh you guys are just coming to
the yard playing great ball and having a
lot of fun doing it so it's been very
good you had three base hits today when
you got the triple and score run in the
fifth inning it was 5-1 but I guess what
epitomizes the streak like this you guys
probably never feel like you're really
out of the game no doubt about it we
just uh you know keep fighting till the
last out's made that's the kind of the
motto we've had all year but uh you know
it's really really come to life here as
of late so uh you know like you
mentioned we feel like we're in every
game so we're just playing hard till the
end there's a younger player on this
team when you look in that Dugout and
there's Nolan Arenado Paul Goldschmidt
Yadi Molina how easy is it just to fall
behind these guys and see what they do
and follow their lead they make it real
easy for me it's uh it's a pleasure to
get to be out there each and every day
with them and uh be able to just talk to
them and learn from them each and every
day so uh you know I'm real lucky but
like you said they lead the way and they
do a great job of it finally on a
personal note for a guy who made his
debut last year in a jacked up year what
is it like to be in front of these
crowds down the stretch part of a
pennant race it's it's amazing uh
everything everything you could dream of
and then some uh the fans brought great
energy all year and it's been uh really
cool to be able to experience the
atmosphere with the crowds this year
like you mentioned didn't play in front
of crowds last year so uh just being
able to experience it and kind of feed
off it's been awesome
death taxes and the St Louis Cardinals
in the postseason they're on their way
again a couple of weeks ago when we
looked at this game on the schedule we
thought maybe the Cardinals would really
be vying for that second wild card spot
they're running away from it with a
12-game winning streak big comeback
Today part of an 8-5 win over the
Brewers we'll step aside and come back
with four the YouTube game of the week
the post game from American Family field
in Milwaukee
if you're one of the thousands who
follow Willy adamus on Instagram you may
be wondering what's with the hashtag
when you get to this level
some sometimes you know things change
you know like you you get a new car you
get house a big house and sometimes you
know you get to your head long ago
adamus decided he wouldn't let it get in
his head as a 17 year old in the
Dominican summer league he first posted
no book bag that was in 2013.
it's a Loosely translated Spanish phrase
and Adama says it reminds him to stay
humble never boast and remember where he
came from which was a small town in the
Dominican Republic where he had loving
parents but not much else that's what
makes me appreciate this God gave me
this opportunity I got to give it to
others willia Thomas loves life and
lives it with humility and is surrounded
by family and friends who wouldn't have
it any other way oh my God
my face probably
thank you
it's our fourth YouTube game
it's incredible
[Music]
oh I see this ball going in the second
deck
[Applause]
Taylor gets it oh my
my father
no I didn't say Pina I said Tyrone
yeah you're for sure doing it again
tomorrow
you have to you have to
oh we got a guy there
I think we got a guy there shot to land
in a glove
we don't have a guy there
chorizo
[Applause]
come on chorizo
[Applause]
I win I win
[Applause]
that wasn't a fair race
I won though
you're just winning all year Corbin
Burns and thank you for the mic'd up
Glory today also we like to do our
curious creators our YouTube creators
that were spending time with us today in
the live game commentary we'll start
with sports store great game to end the
year thank you for a fun season MLB the
playoffs are almost here
yes we tipped our cap to you one more
Austin classic has done a great job in
the chat this year great game of the
Week final thank you MLB YouTube
fantastic season so much fun can't wait
for the future I know you love the mic'd
up content and we've added all year long
Corbin Burns finishing up with a grand
slam prediction that plays out which is
perfect because now if he's talking to
his friends after the game he says I
called it and they go no you didn't and
he just goes here here's the link I
called it and he also called the sausage
race too stay hot Corbin Burns but from
Milwaukee they wish they were as hot as
Corbin Burns because they had this game
five nothing you got to put the game
away desperate for a win I have to give
more credit to the Cardinals for the way
they just came back in this game took
advantage of any little mistake some
walks let the big home runs late and the
Cardinals cashed in five's the number
two five in a row losses for the Brewers
we didn't see Devin Williams he was in
The Dugout he hasn't pitched much this
month he didn't end the season with the
team last year in the playoffs he woke
up wasn't feeling great I believe it was
I don't want to misidentify but
something arm or shoulder related so he
didn't pitch in the postseason in those
couple games losses for the Brewers
against the Dodgers last year I don't
want to say they need him but it would
be nice yeah I don't know what's going
on Scott but he had five days of rest
he's pitched less than four Innings this
month so he really hasn't had a big
workload this month but we saw him in
the Dugout late in the game not in the
bullpen he didn't seem to be an option
when the game was turned over to box
burger and Ashby I did get word go ahead
tell me Craig we'll give it to everyone
live
Devin Williams injured a calf muscle
running in the Outfield a couple days
ago they're hopeful it's not an IL
situation okay so it could be worse
calves are tricky but it's not it's not
an arm or shoulder situation right so
listen they still have the big lead in
the division it's a matter of when they
clinch the division no reason to push
anything with Devon Williams but yeah
going forward they better make sure that
that cap is not a long-term issue
because that is part of a winning
strategy at the end of games from
Milwaukee those guys not only get outs
they don't even let the ball get in play
when you're talking about Williams and
hater yeah look at the width rates in
Major League Baseball haters on the list
Williams is on the list cousins who had
a difficult day today handling this
Cardinals team so it's a final 8-5 St
Louis grabs another win 12 in a row and
we've been winning every week because
we've had the mic'd up players so now
let's bring it all together
and send you this
I mic'd up
so if you want us to be if you want to
say hi to YouTube say hi
hello secondary let's go secondary and
Coach primary hitting coach I'm Mike
walking through
beautiful day for play baseball here in
Arizona how you doing man that's just
today man okay I got a hot mic on heads
up what's up I got a mic I got a mic got
in my uncle I need a translator on this
thing
the words across the bottom of the
screen
[Applause]
no
no
I speak English okay
oh yeah come on YouTube
YouTuber
good for the brand it's good for the
brand for the kids man you gotta do for
the kids
bye
[Applause]
for three
[Applause]
dude
seriously might be the worst maze runner
in the league what are you doing
you should score
what's your score
you got it again
[Applause]
what would you be doing if you didn't
play baseball
oh I I'd probably be a bomb somewhere
honestly we're playing golf didn't you
Homer like two days ago I ran into one
see you got Pop I run into balls we're
gonna take off here
that could have been bad right there
I thought it was a slider dude oh really
dude I can't pick up the ball here bro
yeah
you know what I mean so I like I kind of
like was waiting for it to break and
dude if I didn't I don't think if I have
my pad there if I have a pad bro
[Music]
[Applause]
that's all for you
see everybody
Dia is the best beautiful guy in the
team right there look at her right there
what a life fourth inning I'll just
stroll out what a life
I'll put it in my glove like that
for curveball
slider
or heater
if I throw a change up then I'll somehow
get to it but I don't do that
that's going probably like 27 other
parts
tell you where it ain't going here in
Detroit
I'll tell you what there's a lot of
dudes here with their shirts off kind of
weird
[Applause]
oh can we run that on repeat I love that
that's so good oh it's so good thanks to
all the players that's what's going on
every single day on the personalities
come really to life it's great and then
the postseason is alive in October and
it's coming very soon we're what a week
and a half away from getting this thing
fired up these are the scenarios at the
moment now for the Brewers and Cardinals
fans that were with us today it looks
like Braves and Brewers it looks like
Cardinals and Dodgers for the wild card
at the moment still to be decided in the
NLS but we keep rolling along Dodgers
don't stop winning although they lost
yesterday but the Giants just have had
no quit in them these are two what's
looking like 100 plus win Seasons when
we get to the end of the regular year
one of them will have to take on a team
we just watched today that looks really
good yeah how about if you win let's say
103 games games 104 games
and then you have to put everything on
the line in one game against what is now
the hottest team in baseball the St
Louis Cardinals point there is a big
prize in that National League West and
the prize is staying out of the wild
card game that's why the last week and a
half especially for those teams feels
like the postseason it really does
because they know they need to take
every game right now otherwise you check
out the highlights if you were watching
YouTube today you see a scary St Louis
team there are suddenly not many flaws
for them they're going to be a force
Brewers lose here yes but they should be
in good shape to win the division of
course their magic number is three
there's time to spare so they should be
okay but wow what a day what a finisher
to our schedule on the year and then I
want to do some thank yous it's our last
YouTube game of the season here on our
slate and we've had walk-offs comebacks
like this we've had some of the best in
baseball in terms of teams and
individual players and then I want to
give a special shout out to some of the
crew behind the scenes so I'll start
with Jordan rubimbus our tape operator
puts all the mic'd up content together
what we just saw there uh that's gold
that's what I call it all year it's just
it's gold the mic'd up content and you
can see more of that on Playland on
YouTube but the producer of today's game
Michael Traynor director Jason lab tape
producer Chris Bracy associate director
Carmine arpaya Graphics coordinators
Matt olbaum and Ian Harmon technical
managers Jason Hedgecock and Zach
Christopher technical director Michael
Lang production manager Caitlyn Peterman
today and a special thanks to Jason
secamp and edit turning out sharp
elements all year long special shout out
to our friends at YouTube of course for
another special season full of
innovation what a season on our MLB game
of the week Live on YouTube slate and
thank you to our crew behind the scenes
for getting everything done it's really
appreciated there the true Superstars
for Tom verducci and Brett Dolan I'm
Scott Brun it's been an absolute
pleasure all season long we've enjoying
this ride on the post game show as well
what a game today the Cardinals step in
and eventually stop on Milwaukee's and
it's an 8-5 final they've won 12 in a
row I cannot wait for October baseball
we'll see you next time see you soon on
YouTube
foreign
[Music]
[Music]